Jo, herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 40.
Jawohl.
Wir reden heute über Stadtentwicklung und Gentrifizierung und haben zu Gast Andrej Holm. Herzlich willkommen.
Ja, schönen guten Tag, schönen guten Abend.
Und wollen, dass wir immer ein bisschen mehr Zeit nehmen, um das Themenfeld zu diskutieren und die Fragen, die wir schon alle so hatten, als potenzielle Immobilienheime zu klären. Was bedeutet denn nun eigentlich Gentrifizierung? Also wovon reden wir da eigentlich?
Da haben wir, glaube ich, ganz viele Diskussionen, die sich so überlappen. Wir haben einerseits so eine Alltagsdebatte, die auch in den Zeitungen wiedergespiegelt wird. Die beschreibt Gentrification als, da ändert sich was im Stadtteil, da sind jetzt drei redrige Kinder wegen, da gibt es dann viele Bioläden. Das heißt, es gibt so eine Oberflächenbeschreibung von Veränderungen. Das hat aber nichts mit dem tatsächlich wissenschaftlichen Konzept zu tun von Gentrification. Das hört man, das ist ein Fachbegriff, der kommt aus der geografischen Forschung in England ursprünglich. Und der beschreibt Aufwertungsprozesse, die unmittelbar mit Verdrängung von ärmeren Bevölkerungsgruppen verbunden sind. Das ist so das Kernkonzept und das ist seit den 60er Jahren in eigentlich allen entwickelten westlichen Ländern, also von England, USA, nach Europa zurückkehrend diskutiert worden. Und sagt eigentlich, das ist ein Stadtentwicklungsprozess, der notwendigerweise mit Verdrängung verbunden ist. Ja, sonst würden wir das nicht Gentrification nennen.
Das heißt also die Aufwertung im Sinne von die Preise steigen und die Viertel werden ein bisschen schicker und hübscher und es irgendwie fängt an nach Kaffee zu riechen und so ist aus Sicht der Forschung quasi notwendigerweise mit Verdrängung verbunden?
Nee, nicht alle Aufwertung, aber Aufwertung, die notwendigerweise mit Verdrängung verbunden ist, die würden wir als Identification beschreiben. Und wir haben ja selbst hier in Berlin oder auch in anderen deutschen Großstädten, haben wir ja ganz viele Beispiele aus den 80er Jahren, wo es eine massive Aufwertung der Baustruktur gab, wenn wir an die Stadterneuerung in Hamburg, in Frankfurt, in Berlin, Kreuzberg beispielsweise denken, die überhaupt nicht mit diesen massiven Verdrängungsprozessen verbunden waren. Das heißt, es gibt auch in der eigenen Erfahrung von deutschen Großstädten ja die Situation, dass eine Aufwertung stattfindet, ohne dass es Verdrängung gibt. Deshalb sagt man da auch Stadterneuerung oder so ein poppiger Begriff, der in der Forschung viel benutzt wird, ist dann Revitalisierung oder Reobarnisierung. Das heißt, es gibt eine Reihe von sich überlagernden Konzepten. Identification ist eine Sonderform davon, aber eine, die im Moment eine große Rolle spielt.
Okay, na gut, wenn ich so irgendwie Reobarnisierung höre, dann denke ich auch mal gleich erstmal an das Schlimmste so.
Also ich würde erstmal wissen wollen, wo kommen denn die reichen Leute her? Weil traditionell ist es ja so, Leute, die in eine Stadt ziehen, sind eher arme Landbevölkerung. Die müssen ja irgendwoher kommen. Wo kommen denn die reichen Leute her?
Na es ist tatsächlich ja ein, man muss sich so einen Stadtentwicklungsprozess ein bisschen wie so ein Zyklus vorstellen. Ja, so haben das seit, weiß nicht, den 1920ern auch alle diese Stadtgeografen gemacht, die beobachtet haben, Städte wachsen. Da ziehen Leute, die in die Städte einwandern, danach Arbeit und Glück suchen. Die ziehen dahin, werden reich. Wenn es ihnen gut geht, dann ziehen sie an den Stadtrand und suburbanisieren das Umland mit den Einfamilienhaussiedlungen. Das ist so der Trend, den wir auch in den meisten deutschen Großstädten 60er-, 70er-Jahre eigentlich hatten. Und Gentrification ist jetzt der Prozess in so einem Stadtentwicklungszyklus, wo gesagt wird, jetzt ziehen plötzlich Mittelschichten, die vielleicht noch 10 oder 15 Jahre vorher an den Stadtrand, in so ein Einfamilienhaus gezogen wären. Die finden jetzt die Innenstadt attraktiv und kommen zurück. Deshalb korrespondiert das auch mit dieser Re-Urbanisierung. Also, dass man über viele Jahre hinweg beobachtet hat, Mittelschichten, Besserverdienende suchen sich eigentlich bessere Orte. Am Stadtrand, im Grünen, mit sozusagen mehr Platz zum Wohnen, also besserer Luft, also all den Vorteilen. Und irgendwann kippt das um und wir beobachten, dass Besserverdienende in die Innenstädte ziehen. Und es gibt da letztendlich so drei, vier Gründe, die im Allgemeinen angeführt werden. Das eine ist tatsächlich so Veränderung von Arbeitsbedingungen in der Stadt. Also die Zeit der Industrialisierung und das immer weiter vor die Stadtränder verlagern der Arbeitsplätze nimmt irgendwann in Deutschland in 70er-, 80er-Jahrenende Übergang zur Dienstleistungsgesellschaft, viele Jobs in der Innenstadt, wo es für jeden, der da arbeitet, plötzlich rational ist zu sein, dann will ich auch in der Gegend wohnen. Da muss ich nicht hier jeden Tag hin und her pendeln, dazu kommt, dass es so was wie eine demografische Veränderung gibt, dass wir zur Gesellschaft von Alleinlebenden werden, dass das Familienmodell so ein bisschen aufs Abstellgleis gerät, wenn wir uns die Großstrukturen der Gesellschaft angucken. Das heißt auch, das Potenzial von denen, die in so einer Einfamilienhaussiedlung ihr Habitat finden, wird auch geringer. Als Single- und Alleinstehender macht ein Einfamilienhaus am Stadtrand auch als Mittelschicht mit gutem Einkommen wenig Sinn. Dann will ich Dinge, die in der Innenstadt attraktiv für mich sind, dann auch nutzen. Und dann kommt noch eine Reihe von eher kulturellen Veränderungen, die als maßgeblich für diese Rückkehr in die Städte beschrieben werden dazu.
Das heißt also, die Dienstleistungsgesellschaft ist mehr oder minder so eine Voraussetzung dafür?
Würde ich sagen. Und Dienstleistungsgesellschaft heißt ja auch Übergang zu einer Wissensgesellschaft und längere Ausbildungszeiten. Und wir könnten jetzt auch in Berlin ja vergleichen, was es in 80er Jahren, was es heute an Bildungseinrichtungen, Bildungsfolgeeinrichtungen gibt. Die sind sozusagen überwiegend im Innenstadtbereich auch angesiedelt. Und da gibt es jetzt erst in den letzten Jahren den Trend, das Potenzial zu nutzen, um eine Außenentwicklung wieder zu bestärken. Wenn wir in Berlin beispielsweise an dieses Wissenschaftszentrum Atlas Hof denken, das war schon der Versuch, auch Bildungskluster oder Wissenschaftskluster so ein bisschen weiter außerhalb der Stadt oder innerhalb der Stadtgrenzen weiter außerhalb zu platzieren. Aber es ist ganz eng damit verbunden. Man kann im Prinzip die Zunahme von Dienstleistungsarbeitsplätzen mit Gentrification-Tendenzen oder dem Wunsch, in die Innenstadt zu ziehen. Da kann man relativ gerade Linie ziehen und vielleicht eine Zahl von, also in einer Stadt wie Berlin pendeln jeden Tag ungefähr 70 Prozent derjenigen, die arbeiten, sozusagen in diese Innenstadtbereich rein. Also das heißt, wir haben hier tatsächlich auch die Konzentration von Arbeitsplätzen.
Sehen wir denn dann weniger Leute pendeln, wenn wir in die Innenstadt ziehen? Oder bleibt das ungefähr gleich?
Das kommt natürlich auf die wirtschaftliche Dynamik an. Also wie schnell Arbeitsplätze hinzukommen. Aber es ist eine Anti-Pendel-Bewegung und korrespondiert auch ganz viel mit diesen Versprechen, die es immer gibt, dass man sagt, das ist die Stadt der kurzen Wege, wo du zu Fuß oder mit dem Fahrrad alles erreichst, was du brauchst. Die Kita für die Kinder und dein Arbeitsplatz, das Café, wo du dich mit Freunden triffst und den Sportverein oder was auch immer. Und das ist schon vom Lebensstil her eine Veränderung zu den Alltagsbeziehungen und Mobilitätsbeziehungen, die es in diesen klassischen Außensiedlungen lange Zeit gegeben hat.
Aber eigentlich ist es doch fast wieder eine Rückkehr zu alten Strukturen, wo Arbeiten und Leben jetzt nicht so weit auseinander getrennt waren. Also wenn man sich so jetzt mal so Städte bis Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts anguckt, war ja doch die Durchmischung von Arbeiten und Wohnen relativ stark.
Na wir haben im Westberlin einen Bezirk namens Siemensstadt, der tatsächlich ein altes Siemenswerk war. Und die haben um das Werk herum Wohnungen gebaut für ihre Arbeiter. Also dass die Idee, dass man nicht weit vorm Arbeitsplatz wohnen will, liegt ja auch nahe. Das ist ja effizienzsteigernd auch.
Genau und hatte auch glaube ich, Siemensstadt ist schon so ein Grenzbereich, da ist ja tatsächlich eine sozusagen Werkssiedlung auch mit entstanden. Aber es gab ja ganz viele Nähebeziehungen, die auch über die erschwerten Mobilitäten vor hundert Jahren erklärt werden. Du kannst ja niemanden in zwölf Stunden am Fließband oder in irgendeiner großen Fabrikhalle ausbeuten, wenn der jeden Tag auch noch zwei Stunden Hin- und Rückweg einplanen muss. Dann ist das auch nicht gut für die Art und Weise, wie Industrie funktioniert. Von daher gab es da diese Nähe. Wenn wir uns jetzt aber nochmal überlegen, wie sah die Industriestadt zu Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts oder zur Jahrhundertwende vom 19. zum 20. Jahrhundert aus, dann waren es dreckige Fabrikhallen, Schornsteine, miese Luft. Das heißt, dass es damals eine Reformbewegung gab, die gesagt hat in den 20er Jahren, wir wollen die moderne Stadt so bauen, dass sie funktionsgetrennt ist. Das war so ein Ideal, was von Le Corbusier und anderen in der Karta von Athen in den 20er Jahren diskutiert wurde. Und wo man eigentlich gesagt hat, die Stadt sollte so organisiert sein, dass das Wohnen, die Freizeit und die Arbeit möglichst voneinander getrennt sind. Und das kommt uns heute total absurd vor, weil wir auch Alltagsbeziehungen haben, wo man sagt, ich habe ja auch nicht nur eine Arbeit, sondern ich habe zwei verschiedene Jobs oder habe auch nicht mein ganzes Leben lang denselben Job. Aber unter den damaligen gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen war das erst mal eine fortschrittliche Idee zu sagen, die Leute müssen jetzt nicht im Dreck ihrer Fabriken auch noch wohnen.
Das heißt also, der Rückverdichtung von Arbeiten und Wohnen, was ja quasi das Ideal der meisten Leute ist, dass sie sagen, ich würde da von Fahrrad zur Arbeit fahren können oder jedenfalls mich nicht eine Stunde lang oder zwei irgendwelche Autostraßen lang quälen, ist ja auch so ein gewisses Lebensentwurfsthing. Also so eine gewisse Veränderung von der Industriearbeit, wo man halt hin pendelt lange. So, wenn ich dran denke, so VW zum Beispiel, da sind die irgendwie Quadratkilometer von Parkplätzen, die um dieses Werk sind und wie lange die Leute da fahren, wo sie dann tatsächlich schon Busse haben, um die Leute von den Parkplätzen ins Werk zu kriegen, weil die Parkplätze so groß sind. Und dagegen ist ja so ein Google oder so oder Zalando, die halt versuchen, halt ihre Hauptquartiere in die möglichst angesagten Viertel zu stellen. Ja, doch schon ziemlich so der Gegenentwurf, oder so, ne?
Und jetzt gibt es ja die Kritik, dass du quasi dein Ziel dadurch kaputt machst, dass du diese Schritte einleitest. Weil du die Gegend so weit aufwertest, dass sich dann die Studenten das nicht mehr leisten können. Und deine Arbeitgeber, die Arbeitgeber bauen da ein Palast hin und die Arbeitnehmer können sich dann die Mieten nicht mehr leisten. Ist das zwangsläufig oder ist das nur jetzt halt ein paar Mal passiert?
Nein, das ist schon auch systematisch in den Aufwertungsprozessen eingebunden, dass die Preissteigerung das Ziel davon ist. Aber wir haben jetzt eher über so Stadtentwicklungstypologien gesprochen. Was verändert sich und warum?
Was sind die Treiber?
Passt total an die Stadtstruktur und die Veränderung, die wir gerade erleben. Warum passt die zum Beispiel der Arbeitsweise, wie die in der Gesellschaft organisiert wird? Und was anderes ist ja die Frage, wie wird dieser Stadtumbau oder diese Veränderung der Stadt immobilienwirtschaftlich organisiert? Ich könnte mir ja auch vorstellen, dass ich 100 Prozent Betriebswohnungen habe oder dass eine Stadt einen sehr hohen Anteil von öffentlichen und geförderten Wohnungen hat. Dann ist das überhaupt kein Thema, dass die Mieten unbedingt steigen müssen. Also diese Idee, dass eine gestiegene Attraktivität, eine gestiegene Nachfrage nach einem bestimmten Wohnungsmarktsegment zu einer Preissteigerung führt. Das ist natürlich was, was nur unter Marktverhältnissen ausgeprägt ist. Ich könnte mir ja auch vorstellen, ich habe eine Art Ökodiktatur in der Stadt und verteile die Wohnung so, dass sich möglichst geringe Mobilitätswege für alle ergeben. Ein Verteilungsprinzip könnte ich mir vorstellen. Oder ich könnte mir ein soziales Verteilungsprinzip vorstellen und sagen, ich verteile die Wohnung auf eine Art und Weise, dass alle möglichst in den Nachbarschaften wohnen, wo sie den größten Nutzen aus den sozialen Netzwerken ziehen. Oder so machen wir es jetzt. Ich verteile die Wohnung nach Preis und nach Leistungsfähigkeit bei der Bereitschaft, die Mietpreise oder Eigentumswohnungspreise zu zahlen. Das heißt also, wenn wir von Verdrängung sprechen, dann ist es unmittelbar verbunden mit der Art und Weise, wie die Vergabe von Wohnungen und wie das System von Wohnungsversorgung organisiert ist.
Ich habe jetzt noch den Eindruck, dass wir hier von zwei verschiedenen treibenden Kräften reden. Also bei Le Corbusier und im letzten Jahrhundert klingt das so, als wenn es sozusagen die Regierung oder Stadtplaner, jedenfalls nicht die Unternehmen, so geplant haben. Und dabei die heutigen Einflüsse klingen eher so, als wenn es die Unternehmen machen oder irgendwelche privatwirtschaftlichen Akteuren. Stimmt das?
Klar, waren die 20er Jahre und auch dann die Nachkriegszeit, die waren ja auch sehr stark von der Überzeugung getragen, dass eine Planung der Gesellschaft überhaupt möglich ist. Das sehen wir auch in anderen Bereichen, also in der Wirtschaftsentwicklung oder in der, weiß nicht, auch sozusagen Ausbau von bestimmten Infrastrukturen, die für eine Gesellschaft als wichtig erachtet worden. Dass man alles dachte, wir können sozusagen mit den neuen Technologien im Rücken die Gesellschaft quasi durchdesignen und fertig planen. Und davon haben wir uns natürlich total verabschiedet. Also auch in den eigentlich eigenen Lebenseinstellungen. Ich würde sagen, reagieren wir meistens auf so eine Durchplanung der Gesellschaft, eher allergisch und sagen, wir wollen hier unsere Freiheiten haben. Und so ähnlich funktioniert natürlich auch im Stadtentwicklungsprozess, wo sich staatweit zurückgezogen hat. Und das hat da aber auch mehrere Ursachen. Also es ist jetzt sozusagen nicht nur so, dass wir sagen, wir haben einen kulturellen Wandel und wollen jetzt mehr so prozesshaft, dass sich die Stadt verändert. So hat auch viel damit zu tun. Wie ist denn das Selbstverständnis für öffentliche Verantwortung? Also wofür soll der Staat zuständig sein? Wo soll er die Finger eher draußen lassen? Und da ist dann sicher das Schlagwort von Neoliberalismus, sozusagen auch für Gentrification von Belangen. Also das sich durchgesetzt hat, eine Vorstellung, die sagt, Stadtentwicklung ist vor allen Dingen der Prozess von privaten Akteuren, die sich da irgendwie ins Benehmen setzen. Und da muss der Staat nicht so viel eingreifen. Und wenn wir das aber so wollen, oder wenn die Gesellschaft das so will, dann heißt das, dass sich letztendlich diese Marktlogiken auch als Dauerthema etablieren. Und das ist das, was wir in den letzten Jahren auch beobachtet haben.
Wie lange gibt es denn dieses Modell mit den Investoren überhaupt schon? Dass sozusagen Privatpersonen jetzt nicht nur Häuser bauen, damit ihre Mitarbeiter da wohnen können, sondern mit dem Ziel, über die Mieten Geld zu verdienen. Ist das eine neue Nummer oder wie lange gibt es das schon?
Na, die Idee mit Mietwohnhäusern Geld zu verdienen, das gibt es schon lange. Und wir haben aber inzwischen noch eine neue Form. Also wir können ja auch in den meisten deutschen Großstädten zumindest die Bauten der Gründerzeit, also die so Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts entstanden sind. Das waren ja auch Spekulationsprojekte. Also wo pfiffige Grundstückseigentümer haben gesehen, die Stadt macht hier einen großen Plan. Dieser berühmte Hobrechtplan, der diese sozusagen Außenentwicklung der Stadt vorhergesehen hat. Dann haben die da die Grundstücke aufgekauft und haben die an sogenannte Terrenggesellschaften weiterverkauft, die das dann entwickelt haben. Und dann wurde dort dieser, was wir heute ja wieder schön finden, aber eigentlich ein hochverdichteter Mietskasernenbau hingestellt. Wenn wir uns in Berlin so Gebiete wie Wedding oder Prenzlauer Berg anschauen, dann, wenn man da Luftbildaufnahmen hat, dann sieht man ja, das ist sozusagen eine eigentlich hyperdicht bebaute Fläche mit mikrokleinen Höfen da drin. Und das ist ein Ergebnis der Grundstückspekulation damals. In Berlin haben die nämlich die Preise für die Grundstücke nicht nach Quadratmetern berechnet, sondern nach der Länge an der Straße. Also du hast sozusagen Straßenland gekauft. Und aus der Perspektive war es für alle, die Häuser entwickeln wollten, eine total ökonomisch-rationale Entscheidung, möglichst ein schmales Stück zu holen, was sich in die Tiefe eben bis zur Hälfte des Blocks, weil dann kommt ja das Grundstück vom Gegenüber, Plane. Und so sind diese Häuser mit den zwei, drei Hinterhöfen entstanden. Und wenn man die Grundstücke von oben anschaut, dann sagt man auch, das sind so Handtuchflächen. Also es sieht aus wie...
Mit zweites, drittes Hinterhaus dann.
Ja, ich dachte mal, ich hab mich da schon immer gefragt, ist das ein Berlinerleingang gewesen oder gibt es das auch anderswo, diese Art von... Weil ich hab das irgendwie noch nie woanders gesehen, oder jedenfalls nicht so ausgeprägt.
In Berlin war es tatsächlich ein Ergebnis von dem eigentlich gut gemeinten Stadtplan, den James Hobrecht, der war der sozusagen Chef Stadtplaner irgendwie in Preußen, also sozusagen vom König auch direkt bestellt. Und der hatte vor allen Dingen die Horrorbeispiele aus Paris und London, die ja einen früheren Stadtentwicklungsprozess durchlaufen haben, vor Augen und hat gesagt, dieses ungeordnete Wachsen, das wollen wir in Preußen nicht haben. Und hat deshalb gesagt, ich plan hier ordentliche Straßen und war sie Ringstraßen, die die miteinander verbinden und planen hier Plätze ein, die dann für Grünflächen auch sorgen. Und in diesem Straßenraster sind letztendlich mehr oder weniger quadratische Blöcke entstanden. Und dann sind die Terrain-Gesellschaften gekommen und haben gesagt, so jetzt haben wir den Straßenplan, dafür ist der Staat auch verantwortlich, diese Straßen zu bauen. Und wir teilen uns jetzt die Grundstücke auf. Und weil es damals dieses Prinzip gab, eher anreinende Länge an der Straße zu kaufen statt Fläche, ist dann diese Struktur entstanden. Dann sind diese vielen dicht besiedelten Häuser entstanden. Man kann sagen, eine gut gemeinte Planung plus Bodenspekulation hat zu dieser hochverdichteten Form der Mietskaserne geführt.
Das heißt, diese Logik war wahrscheinlich eher so ein Straßenangrenzfläche, ist eine Möglichkeit, da Läden unterzubringen oder so. Und damit die Möglichkeit, mehr Profit zu machen. Und dann haben sie sich nicht vorstellen können, dass jemand dann noch drittes, viertes Hinterhaus da reinbaut.
Genau, also war ja auch für die damalige Zeit. Also Berlin ist ja viele Städte in der Zeit der Industrialisierung. Unglaublich schnell gewachsen. Und in der Zeit vorher gab es ja im Prinzip keine reale Erfahrung mit einem kompakten Mietswohnungsbau. Ja, so ein Wohnungsbau hieß in der Regel, dass da zwei oder drei Stöcke Gehäuser entstanden.
Und dann noch ein Garten hinter.
Vielleicht eine ländliche Prägung, wo sozusagen auch auf schmalen Grundstücken dann hinten noch eine Kuh stand oder eine Esel oder irgendetwas. Und das in dieser schnell wachsenden Stadt, wo sich die Bevölkerung innerhalb von zehn, zwölf Jahren ja immer verdoppelt hat, plötzlich eine völlig andere Form des Bauens entstanden ist. Das hatte der Plan nicht vorgesehen. Und dieser Plan, der war so ein Minimalplan. Also der hat die Straßen gebaut. Also die Straßen, die müssen eine bestimmte Breite haben. Die haben dann diese berühmte Berliner Traufhöhe. Also die Häuser sind ja auch überall gleich hoch. Also 21,6 Meter, also 21,60 Meter. Und diese Traufhöhe war entstanden, weil man gesagt hat, die Straßen haben eine bestimmte Breite. Und die Traufhöhe bemisst sich danach, dass wenn so ein Haus irgendwie mal zusammenbrechen sollte, dass es sozusagen nicht das gegenüberliegende Haus auch gleich mit kaputt macht. So kommt die Höhe zustande.
Achso, ich dachte, das wäre Feuerwehrleiter.
Das sind ja alles geschichten hier.
Und die zweite Rahmenbedingung, die es gab, war, dass die berühmte Berliner Feuerpumpe in den Höfen einmal im Kreis gedreht werden kann, damit die rein und wieder rausfahren kann. Und daran war sozusagen so eine Art Minimal-Rahmengesetz. Kleiner darf der Hof nicht werden. Und das waren die Rahmenbedingungen. Dann sind uns da richtige Spekulanten gekommen. Das war damals auch schon internationales Kapital. Wir hatten hier in Prenzlauer Berg im Nordosten von Berlin, da waren zum Beispiel relativ viele holländische Terrain-Gesellschaften, die, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die ihr Geld herhatten, aber die hatten jedenfalls relativ viel und haben dann hier im Prinzip den Wohnungsbau mitorganisiert. Und sozusagen in einem fast schon industriellen Fertigungsweise, also das auch auf Plätzen, die heute als Grünplätze bekannt sind. Da gab es so richtige Ziegeleien, wo die Steine gebrannt wurden, die dann gleich verbaut wurden. Und das war tatsächlich ein völliger Wechsel von allem, was man in der Stadtentwicklung bis dahin kannte. Und dann war man auch entsprechend nicht darauf vorbereitet, als Planungsbehörde irgendwas zu machen. Und das ist vielleicht ein Vergleich, den wir auch zu heute ziehen können. Die Stadt war natürlich froh, dass viele Wohnungen entstanden sind. Also da kommen sozusagen Zehntausende pro Monat in die Stadt und suchen Wohnung. Und du hast einen Mechanismus gefunden, wo Wohnungen gebaut werden, also die dann eine Reihe von hygienischen und sozialen Problemen produzieren. Aber die bauen erst mal die Wohnungen, die gebraucht werden. Da hat damals auch natürlich niemand gesagt, es ist irgendwie ein unfaires Geschäftsmodell oder es sind keine akzeptablen Wohnverhältnisse. Alles Dinge, die dann ja erst in der Folgezeit entstanden sind, nachdem diese Häuser errichtet wurden. Und dann, weil die doch relativ teuer waren für die damalige Zeit, ja von denen, die damals da gearbeitet haben, in totaler Überbelegung belegt wurden. Also wenn man sich dann sozusagen vorstellt, wer hat in so einer Wohnung, die heute wieder attraktiv ist, in Prenzlauer Berg gewohnt mit zwei, drei Zimmern, dann war das im Durchschnitt, glaube ich, pro Zimmer fünf bis sechs Personen. Also so dicht besiedelt haben die dort dann gelebt. Und dann mussten auch die Kinder zur Arbeit geschickt werden, damit die Miete gezahlt werden kann. Also all diese Horrorgeschichten, die es zur Jahrhundertwende gab. Und das hat man dann erst später aufgelöst, indem man gesagt hat, hier haben wir die ersten statistischen Untersuchungen, die es gibt dann so um die Jahrhundertwende. Und dann erst kommen so Auflagen, dass jede Person eine bestimmte Quadratmeterzahl zur Verfügung zu stehen hat und sonst das als Überbelegung bezählt. Und da auch so ein interessanter Aspekt. Ich glaube Breslau, also Heutree-Wotswaf, war auch so eine schnell industrialisierte Stadt mit so einem Gründerzeitbestand. Da gab es die erste Wohnungsstatistik auf dem damaligen deutschen Reichsgebiet oder was auch immer. Und die haben damals als Konsequenz zum Beispiel festgelegt, dass jede Person eine bestimmte Kubikmeterzahl an Luft zur Verfügung haben muss. Also wie sich auch so standards, also wenn wir heute sagen, wie viel Raum sollte eigentlich jedem zur Verfügung stehen? Gibt es im Laufe der Geschichte eine ganze Reihe, sozusagen erste Annäherung an solche Themen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das generell kann, aber ich habe in meiner Kindheit bei so einer Reise nach Ostberlin mal gesehen, dass diese typischen Gebäude von vorne so ganz gut aussahen. Aber im ersten Hinterhof war schon so ein bisschen gammeliger. Im zweiten Hinterhof man schon gedacht so, oh und der dritte Hinterhof sah aus wie eine Bauruine. Kann man das verallgemeinern? War das auch damals schon so, dass je weiter hinten ist, desto schlechter?
Na, Bauruinen wurden natürlich nicht ursprünglich gebaut.
Aber ich meine so, das ist außer wie, oh Gott, hier will ich lieber nicht.
Ja, na, das ist total die Planung für diese berühmte Berliner Mischung. Das geht auch noch auf diesen Hobrechtplan von 1871, 73, in den 60ern schon, 1964 glaube ich. Also so im 19. Jahrhundert hat er diesen Straßenplan gemacht und diese Vorgaben gemacht und der war ein großer Anhänger davon, dass man sagt, und in diesen Wohnungen, da soll dann sich die gesamte Gesellschaft abbilden und man hat dann, das sieht man auch heute noch in den Häusern, diese sozusagen Bell-Etage, also dass das in dem ersten Stock, die Höhen der Wohnung auch noch höher sind, oben wird es dann immer kleiner oder sieht man auch, wenn man diese Gründerzeithäuser sieht, dann sind die ersten zwei Etagen vielleicht noch so mit Ornamenten geschmückt und oben wird es dann schlichter, die Fenster werden auch kleiner und da hatte der diese Grundidee, dass in diesen Bell-Etage, da sollte das Bürgertum wohnen, der Direktor der Schule, der Apotheker, Er war der Fabrikbesitzer sogar von kleinen Unternehmen und da drüber sollten dann so die Facharbeiter wohnen und weiter oben dann die Ärmeren und ganz hinten in den Hinterhäusern. Die hatten ja auch schlechtes Licht, da sollte dann noch sein das Proletariat oder Subproletariat wohnen. Und die Idee, die der Hobrecht damals hatte, war, dass die alle ja durch denselben Gang zur Straße gehen und dass das der Ort ist, wo sich diese unterschiedlichen sozialen Schichten, die durch die Ungleichheiten des Industriekapitalismus entstehen, dann kennenlernen und gegenseitige Hilfe organisieren können.
Also schon so sozialromantischer Ansatz ein bisschen, ja?
Ja, ich glaube, als Hobrecht das aufgeschrieben hat, gab es noch gar keine Sozialdemokratie. Aber bis heute hält sich sozusagen dieser Mythos der sozialen Mischung. Und eigentlich ist das total zynisch. Also weil der beschreibt auch, dass die sozusagen die Kinder vom Apotheker halt da den denselben Weg durch den Hof benutzen, wenn sie zu ihrem Gymnasium gehen, wie die Kinder aus den Arbeiterfamilien, die vielleicht mit 13, 14 schon zur Kinderarbeit in die Fabriken gehen. Aber da begegnet die sich halt und man lernt sich halt kennen. Und wenn dann im Hinterhaus die Frau sowieso bettlägerig ist, dann kennt man die, weil die schon vorne auch mal die Wohnung geputzt hat und dann hat man ein Löffelchen Suppe für die übrig. Also so eine Vorstellung besteht da. Und das zynische daran ist, dass das letztendlich die damals wirklich fassbare und für jeden sichtbare Ungleichheit überhaupt nicht in Frage gestellt wird.
Aber in Architektur gegossen wird.
In Architektur, also auch noch verfestigt, weil man davon ausgeht, dass die sich sowieso nicht auflöst. Aber so eine Art Milderungstatbestand diskutiert wird, dass wenn die ganz Arm und die Reicheren sozusagen Kontakt zueinander haben, dann entsteht da irgendwas Gemeinsames, was diese Ungleichheit erträglich macht. Und das ist ein Ergebnis auch von dieser Angst, die es aus den anderen europäischen Metropolen gab, wo man nämlich ja nicht nur Angst vor den gefährlichen Klassen hatte, sondern wie in Paris auch Angst davor, dass diese gefährlichen Klassen, Proletarier, Subproletarier, dass die sozusagen an einem Ort auch unkontrolliert dann leben.
Verstehe. Das sind die kritischen Massabdegen, ne?
Diese Idee von Paris Hausmann, der sozusagen die großen Magistralen dort durch die proletarischen Viertel geschlagen hat, das war ja auch sozusagen eine Sicherheitsmaßnahme. Also nicht nur, weil das irgendwie für die Stadtplanung schön aussah, dass es gerade Straßen gibt, sondern das ist ja damals auch begründet worden, die Straßen müssen gerade angelegt sein, damit die Kanonen da durchfahren können, wenn man mal einen Aufstand bekämpfen muss.
Das war die offizielle Begründung?
Eine der offiziellen Begründungen. Also gab es relativ viele, aber so eine Maßstäbe spielten damals eine Rolle. Und Berlin war schlauer, also war ein bisschen hinten dran und dachte, wir lassen hier gar nicht erst so eine Wucherung von gefährlichen Vierteln und gefährlichen Klassen entstehen, sondern wir planen das von Anfang an in geordneten Bahnen. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen aus der Hand geraten, unter anderem weil dann spätestens nach dem ersten Weltkrieg in Berlin diese bürgerliche Schicht, die in der Bel-Etage wohnen sollte, die war plötzlich gar nicht mehr da. Und die ist in der Menge der Besserverdienenden, die hat sich reduziert und die sind dann mehr oder weniger alle nach Charlottenburg gezogen, wo es sozusagen die traditionellen bürgerlichen Viertel gab und dann standen diese sozusagen schön gemachten Etagen im ersten Stock, die standen dann leer und das ist so, wenn man in den alten Baubüchern schaut, das ist so die Zeit in Zwanzigerjahren und dann auch, wenn dann die Wirtschaftskrise Berlin erfasst, sind ganz viele Wohnungsteilungen unternommen worden. Es sind also gar nicht mehr diese bürgerliche Wohnung mit den fünf oder sechs großen Räumen und dem Dienstboten- und Dienstmädchenaufgang entsteht, sondern da werden dann die Wohnungen geteilt und dann in kleineren Einheiten weitervermietet.
Falls Bürgertum keine Lust mehr hatte.
Es gab wenig Bürgertum und das Wenige hat sich in die traditionellen bürgerlichen Bereiche zurückgezogen. Also so wird es jedenfalls in den Beschreibungen aus der Zeit dargestellt.
Warum die Häuser in Charlottenburg schon so deutlich anders aussehen als in Prenzlauer Berg oder weiter draußen.
Die sind ein bisschen früher entstanden und die haben auch nicht diese vielen Hinterhäuser. Also vielleicht noch einen Seitenflügel.
Ist mehr so ein großer Hof, wo rumgebaut wird oder so. Und auch nach oben wäre die Wohnung jetzt nicht so viel kleiner und so. Interesting.
Ich habe noch mal eine Frage zuvorhin. Da ging es mir ja darum, wo die Reichen herkommen bei der Gentrifizierung. Und da habe ich so ein bisschen Eindruck gewonnen, dass sind Leute, die innerhalb derselben Stadt umziehen. Gibt es da irgendwelche Zahlen zu? Weil in Berlin gibt es immer diese, ich sag mal Vorurteil, dass die Schwaben herziehen. Aber wenn die jetzt zu 80 Prozent gar nicht von außerhalb kommen, sondern innerhalb derselben Stadt umziehen, das würde das ja ein bisschen ändern. Ist das so? Kann man das sagen?
Es ist immer beides. Eine Stadt wie Berlin war lange Zeit davon geprägt, dass es eine unglaublich hohe, wie heißt es dann immer schön, Binnenfluktuation gibt. Also Umzüge innerhalb der Stadt. Auch was viele aus dem eigenen Erleben noch kennen, Familienkonstellation verändert sich. Wir suchen mal schnell eine neue Wohnung. Spielte auch keine Rolle, weil der Mietpreis ungefähr gleichbleibend war zu der bisherigen Wohnung. Also man hat sich sozusagen die Wohnung gesucht, die jeweils gerade passte oder ist vielleicht auch, der Schule wird von den Kindern hinterhergezogen oder dort, wo der Lieblingsverein spielt oder was auch immer. Und gleichzeitig hast du aber eine Zuwanderung, die von außen kommt, die war in Berlin in 1990er Jahren nicht so ausgeprägt. Also da sind gar nicht so viele von außerhalb nach Berlin gezogen. Aber seit Jahrjahtausendwende gibt es massiven Zuzug nach Berlin. Also da kommen 180.000 bis 200.000 pro Jahr, ziehen zu, ziehen auch immer welche weg. Also das jetzt so ein Saldo von 40.000, 50.000 Zuzugsgewinnen gibt an Bevölkerung. Und bei diesen Zuzügen von außen, da ist ein typisches Muster, eigentlich in fast allen Städten, dass die erstmal in die Innenstadt ziehen. Also die sozusagen, wer von außen kommt, zieht mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit erstmal in die Innenstadtbezirke. Und es hat verschiedene Gründe. Zum einen, dass da viele kleine Wohnungen sind, die eine große Fluktuation haben. Das hat den Grund, dass Innenstadtbezirke in der Regel außerhalb der Stadt schon bekannt sind. Das heißt, wenn ich von außerhalb jetzt überlege, wo will ich in Berlin wohnen, und ich sag dir, du könntest nach Friedrichshagen ziehen oder nach...
Du müsstest erstmal nachgucken, wo das ist.
Genau, du müsstest nachgucken, wo das ist. Oder nach Lichtenberg. Also dann gibt es sozusagen ein paar Bezirke. Außenbezirke, die haben schon einen schlechten Ruf. Also wenn ich sage, du kannst hier in Spandau oder in Rheinikendorf im Märkischen Viertel, also das zieht niemand nach Berlin direkt dorthin. Aber wenn man sagt, Innenstadt, irgendwie Mitte, Prenzlauer Berg, Kreuzberg, also das sind halt die Orte, die man kennt und wo man auch zuerst nach Wohnungen sucht. So und das heißt also da kommt sozusagen schon beides zusammen, sowohl Zuwanderung von außen als auch Binnenwanderung, die es gibt und Binnenwanderung hat sich in den letzten Jahren im Gegensatz zu diesen Außenwanderung ganz deutlich reduziert. Also und das hat wieder viel damit zu tun, dass die Neuvermietungsmieten, selbst wenn du nur einen 3 oder 4 Jahre alten Mietvertrag hast, plötzlich deutlich darüber liegen. Das heißt, die Hemmschwelle zum Umziehen, die ist massiv gestiegen. Also Leute rennen im Moment eher zum Baumarkt und holen sich irgendwie dicke Bretter und Balken, um Hochbett zu bauen, als nur weil da jetzt noch ein Kind gekommen ist, eine größere Wohnung zu suchen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen über die zu beobachtenden Phänomene geredet, aber eigentlich haben wir ja Stadtentwicklung gehabt und da frag ich mich, nehmen wir mal an, ich wäre jetzt der Bürgermeister, welche Hebel hätte ich denn überhaupt, um irgendwie Einfluss zu nehmen? Also ich kann ja, was kann ich überhaupt tun, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas beobachte und gegensteuern will oder ich möchte jetzt irgendeine Richtung vorgeben?
Na, du kannst das tun, was der Staat in allen anderen Bereichen eigentlich auch macht und politikwissenschaftlich gesprochen gibt es so die drei großen Steuerungsmedien, die die Staat in der Hand hat. Also die heißen Geld, Recht und Eigentum. Also ich kann als Staat entweder sagen, ich habe Geld und sozusagen erkaufe mir irgendetwas, also zum Beispiel einen sozialen Wohnungsbau oder eine Belegungsbindung oder kaufe mir ein Grundstück und baue selber ein Haus drauf. Also das heißt Förderprogramme oder ich kann natürlich auch steuern, wenn ich, weiß nicht, die Steuern selber sozusagen beeinflüsse, ja, mit Einnahmen. So ein zweiter Weg, der im Moment eher eng vog ist, weil er kein Geld kostet, ist das Steuern mit Recht. Ja, ich mache ein neues Gesetz, eine neue Verordnung, versuche irgendwelche Auflagen, G und Verbote in der Stadtentwicklung zu etablieren. Und da ist natürlich das Problem, dass ich dieses Recht auch immer wieder neu durchsetzen muss und das gleichzeitig nur Sinn macht, wenn meine Kontroll- und Sanktionskapazitäten als Staat auch steigen. Und wir sind ja in Berlin im Moment gerade die Weltmeister der Verordnung. Also wir haben eine Umwandlungsverordnung, eine Zweckentfremdungsverbotsverordnung, eine Kündigungsschutzklauselverordnung für Umwandlungsfälle. Also sozusagen, also alle Mietpreisbremse haben wir auch eingeführt.
Erklär doch mal, was das alles ist. Ich habe ja keine Ahnung.
Können wir gleich machen. Ich versuche erst mal die Prinzipien so ein bisschen zu erklären. Aber das Grundprinzip ist, wenn ich eine Verordnung mache, dann will ich private Initiative in irgendeine Richtung lenken, in die gewünschte. Das kann der Bürgermeister oder seine Verwaltung ja immer versuchen. Das funktioniert aber nur, das kennen wir auch von allen anderen Verordnungen, wenn es jemanden gibt, der das kontrolliert und auch bestraft. Also ich kann, wenn ich eine Straße habe, wo noch nie das Ordnungsamt vorbeigekommen ist, hält sich auch niemand an das Parkverbot. Aber wenn da die Strafzettel regelmäßig verteilt werden, dann setzt sich das Parkverbot, was da gibt, dann auch durch. So ähnlich ist das mit vielen Auflagen im Wohnungsbereich auch. So, dritte, also Geld, Recht, dritte Ebene, wo der Staat einen unmittelbaren Zugriff hat, ist, wenn ihm was gehört. Wenn ihm Grundstücke gehören, wenn ihm Wohnungen gehören, dann kann man mit den eigenen Wohnungsbaugesellschaften oder mit den städtischen oder öffentlichen Liegenschaften, da kann man natürlich Einfluss nehmen auf das, was da passiert. Und diese drei Steuerungsinstrumente, die gibt es in Berlin sozusagen in unterschiedlicher Menge. Wir sind ja immer noch eine hochverschuldete Stadt. Das heißt, das Thema Geld war lange Zeit eins, was eigentlich nur als Sparzwang diskutiert wurde. Alles, was wirklich substanziell Stadtentwicklung hätte beeinflussen können, soziale Wohnungsbauprogramme, Programme für eine mietendämpfende Modernisierung, ist alles zusammengestrichen worden. Thema Eigentum als staatliches Instrument, ähnliche Geschichte, weil hochverschuldet mussten Wohnungsbaugesellschaften verkauft werden, weil hochverschuldet hat man über 15 Jahre hinweg die öffentlichen Liegenschaften zum Höchstpreis verkauft und dann fehlen die plötzlich. So, und dann bleibt dieses Recht übrig, mit dem man dann versucht, private Interessen einzugrenzen.
Ja. Wie viel Eigentum hat denn der Staat überhaupt noch? Also wir hören in den letzten Jahren, ich als unbeteiligter, habe immer nur das verkauft, das verkauft, hier verkauft, da verkauft. Gibt es da überhaupt noch was oder ist das eher so?
Na kommt doch an. Wir haben, wir haben, das klingt jetzt erstmal viel, wir haben fast 300.000 Wohnungen in den Beständen der landeseigenen Wohnungsunternehmen. Das ist bei 300.000. Das ist in der Stadt mit, wir sind dreieinhalb Millionen Einwohner, haben ungefähr 200.000 Wohnungen in der Stadt, 300, 2 Millionen Wohnungen in der Stadt, 300.000 davon gehören dem Land Berlin, kann man jetzt rechnen, 15 Prozent ungefähr. Dazu kommt, dass es eine ganze Reihe von Liegenschaften noch gibt, die der Stadt gehören. Da ist allerdings der meiste Teil in den letzten Jahren verkauft worden. Liegenschaften heißt Grundstücke, in der Regel welche, wo noch irgendeine Restruine drauf stand oder auch potenzielle Baugrundstücke, die gerade in der Berliner Innenstadt an ganz vielen Stellen vorhanden waren. Wenn man sich den gesamten Mauerstreifen oder was auch immer anschaut, da gab es viele städtische Grundstücke, die sind zum Beispiel verkauft worden. Und eine genaue Zahl gibt es bei den Wohnungen. Bei den Grundstücken gibt es das nicht. Das ist aber in Berlin von denen, die sich stadtpolitisch engagieren, seit, weiß nicht, bestimmt zehn Jahren, Dauerforderung. Wir wollen ein Kataster haben, ein öffentlich zugängliches Kataster, wo gezeigt wird, wie viele öffentliche Grundstücke es gibt. Und es gibt auch diese Forderung zu sagen, ganz egal, wie hoch verschuldet Berlin im Moment ist, stoppt diesen Verkauf von Liegenschaften. Wer weiß, ob wir die noch mal brauchen. Und im Moment ist ja so, in diesen dicht besiedelten Innenstadtgebieten, wo jetzt überraschenderweise nach 15 Jahren Gentrification tatsächlich Familien mit vielen Kindern wohnen, die Schulplätze brauchen, gibt es keine Grundstücke, um eine Schule zu bauen. Also neuestes Beispiel ist ja dieser Streit in der Rigaer Straße, wo alle Schulen, alle Grundschulen sind völlig überbelegt. Das nächste Schulamt weiß nicht, wie alle Kinder mit Schulplätzen versorgt werden sollen. Und eigentlich müsste jetzt eine neue Schule gebaut werden. Es gibt einfach kein Grundstück, auf dem das geschehen könnte.
Weil die Stadt schon alle Grundstücke verkauft hat vor Jahren.
Ja, so ein Innenstadtbereich natürlich auch ein extremes Beispiel, weil da gibt es sowieso wenig freie Grundstücke, weil es ja schon gebaut ist.
Ich meine gerade in der Rigaer, da gab es ja irgendwie allerhand so alten Kohlenhöfe und irgendwelche Bombenlücken und so gab es ja da reichlich. Die halt nur dann jetzt in den letzten fünf Jahren zugebaut worden.
Genau, die sind zugebaut worden oder sind an Private gegeben oder wurden, als es noch möglich gewesen wäre, wurde es verpasst von Privaten einzukaufen. Jetzt gibt es ja da den Streit um das eine Baugrundstück in der Rigaer Straße, wo jetzt diskutiert wird, ob der Bezirk da nicht den privaten Investor das abkauft. Aber das wird jetzt zu so einem exorbitant hohen Preis nur noch geschehen können, weil der Privat jetzt sagt, das ist hier beste Lage. Ich habe hier irgendwie ein Luxus-Apartment geplant. Da müsst ihr mich jetzt aber ordentlich entschädigen, wenn ich euch das Grundstück zur Verfügung stelle. Dann wird es natürlich so eine Abwägung. Aber als Stadt hast du natürlich auch eine Verantwortung dafür, dass genügend Infrastruktur da ist. Wenn Schulen gebraucht werden, kann man auch nicht sagen, liebe Familien in Friedrichshain, es gibt zwar die allgemeine Schulpflicht, aber zieht mal nach Rheiningen doch. Ja oder fahrt eure Kinder nach Marzahn, da sind noch drei Plätze frei in der Klasse.
Das ist auch scheiße.
Die interessante Frage ist ja am Ende, ja diese Marktmechanismen, also die haben wir jetzt ja schon in verschiedenen Stellen so ein bisschen gestriffen. Und man kann jetzt argumentieren, dass halt so der natürliche Lauf der Dinge, ist halt so das, was irgendwie so passiert. Der Kapitalismus hat sich dafür entschieden, dass der Markt halt irgendwie das effizienteste Mittel zur Alloziierung von Ressourcen ist. Aber wir sehen ja an diesen Stellen eigentlich, dass es ja schon sehr lange so ist, dass man offensichtlich ja nicht dieser Meinung war. Also dass also quasi aus so einem Stadtplan alleine, also schon zu sagen, hier ist jetzt Straße und du kannst halt irgendwie nur in diesem und jenen Rahmenbedingungen bauen, ist ja eigentlich schon ein Eingriff in den Markt. Also man hätte ja auch sagen können, so hier baut man ja viel Spaß. Also was hat man dann eigentlich so gelernt aus, so der mittlerweile zweieinhalb Jahren oder sowas, wo man versucht, so Stadtentwicklung irgendwie so ein bisschen zu steuern? Also gibt es so Sachen, die funktionieren? Also gibt es so Dinge, wo man sagt, okay, weil was wir immer wieder sehen, sind ja so, dass man sagt, okay, man versucht halt eine Regulierung und dann gibt es wieder irgendwie so ein paar fette Immobilienvorschlüsse, die dann halt sich drum rumwieseln oder halt irgendwie ein Schluffloch finden oder die Regulierung irgendwie hacken und irgendwie oder sich daran vorbei korrumpieren oder sonst irgendwie sowas.
Na und es gibt so Gebiete, wo das immer im Kreis geht, was gerade hip ist. Ja, sieht man da eine klare Richtung bei der Stadtentwicklung oder ist das eher im Kreis oder gibt es irgendwie Konsens darüber, was jetzt gut ist und was nicht?
Nein, dann wäre es einfach. Also vielleicht passt das ganz gut zusammen. Also die eine Idee von, also wenn wir jetzt jenseits von so autoritären Regimen staatliches Handeln betrachten, dann ist ja die Hauptlegitimation, dass man sagt, mit dem staatlichen Handeln wird das Allgemeinwohl in irgendeiner Weise durchgesetzt. Das heißt, also je nach Verfasstheit definiert man dann, was ist das Allgemeinwohl? Die Stadt soll nicht zu dicht sein, von der Bebauung her, da muss genügend Platz für Grünflächen, für Infrastruktur, für irgendetwas da sein. Also das heißt, so ein planbares, geplantes Wachstum ist häufig im Zentrum von staatlichen Handeln. Und wenn du fragst, was man in 150 Jahren Stadtplanung gelernt hat, dann ist der eine Punkt, dass man relativ weit tatsächlich ist mit den Instrumenten, wo man sagt, wenn die Stadt erweitert wird, also wenn ich sozusagen neue Stadtviertel brauche, dann gibt es relativ klare Abläufe und Vorgaben, man kann jetzt nicht einfach irgendwo irgendjemand, irgendein Haus hinbauen, sondern da muss ein Bebauungsplan gemacht werden, da muss geschaut werden, dass es eine verkehrliche Anbindung gibt, da muss geschaut werden, dass es die Infrastrukturen gibt, die es für den Wohnungsbau gibt. Und das sind relativ etablierte Mechanismen für die Stadtplanung. Das, womit sich Stadtplanung aber lange Zeit überhaupt nicht beschäftigt hat, ist, was passiert dann in der schon gebauten Stadt, wenn da plötzlich massive Eigentümerwechsel stattfinden, was passiert, gab es auch lange Zeit kein Instrument, wenn Marktakteure, also Eigentümer von Mietswohnhäusern über viele Jahre hinweg entscheiden, wir renovieren die jetzt einfach nicht mehr, wir sparen uns dieses Geld und leben sozusagen von dem Mietertrag, weil so richtig viel rausholen kann man aus diesen Häusern auch nicht. Und wenn es gerade keinen Bedarf an sanierten Altbauten gibt, dann ist das schrittweise Runterfahren der Qualität immer noch eine relativ effektive Geldquelle gewesen, weil die Mietpreise tatsächlich immer über den Ausgaben lag, die ich hab. Und wenn ich die Einnahmen nicht steigern kann, dann reduziere ich halt die Ausgaben. So ein typischer Fall von sozusagen Rendite durch Desinvestition.
Von der Substanzleben.
Ja, kennen wir in anderen Wirtschaftsbereichen auch. Ist im Wohnungsbereich leider damit verbunden, dass die Wohnqualität für alle die, die auf eine Wohnung in diesen Desinvestitionsgebieten angewiesen sind, weil sie sich nichts besseres leisten können, sich deutlich verschlechtert. Und dann, und dafür gibt es eben wenig Regulierung, ist irgendwann der Moment, wo sich aus einer ökonomischen Perspektive der Wechsel in eine Investitionsstrategie wieder lohnt. Wann lohnt sich also die Investition in ein ramponiertes Altbaugebiet, dann wenn die Lücke zwischen dem derzeitigen Ertrag und dem potenziellen Ertrag am größten ist. Also das ist die Investitionslücke oder die Ertragslücke, die geschlossen werden soll. Und da sehen wir, und das ist das ökonomische Geheimnis von Gentrification an ganz vielen Stellen, dass diese Ertragslücke eben nicht unbedingt dort am größten ist, wo ich den höchsten Mietpreis in der ganzen Stadt erzielen kann. Den kann ich wahrscheinlich immer noch im Grunewald erzielen oder in sozusagen ganz hübsch gemachten Häusern in Charlottenburg. Aber die Ertragslücke heißt auch, ich versuche sozusagen einen Sprung von einer ganz niedrigen Ertragslage in eine möglichst hohe zu bekommen. Und dann trifft es nämlich plötzlich Viertel, die ziemlich abgerockt sind mit geringen Bodenpreisen, mit geringen Mieten. Die sind für eine Aufwertung natürlich besonders interessant. Da kann ich mit einer Modernisierungsmaßnahme oder mit einer Veränderung der Bausubstanz tatsächlich den größten Mietsprung plötzlich erzielen.
Und das ist natürlich die Viertel, die interessant für Künstler, Studenten und so weiter sind, die dann da halt Leben reinbringen.
Genau, und dieses mit dem Leben reinbringen. Also ich bin inzwischen total, also relativ fest der Verzeugung, dass dieses Schließen der Ertragslücke nicht wegen der Studierenden stattfindet, sondern dass das so eine...
Nee, das ist ja der Mechanismus dann. Also ich meine, das ist ja was wir hier zum Beispiel gesehen haben, hier mit dem Stadtbad hier um die Ecke. Wir sitzen in der Raumfahrtagentur und wir waren ja vorher im Stadtbad da. Und da hat der Solothat ja auch so einen Investor gekauft.
Na, aber vorher war da Party immer von...
Nee, nee, nee, lass mich mal ausreden. Ich erzähl mir die Geschichte von Anfang an. Und der wollte ja da ursprünglich, wollte der glaube ich einen Supermarkt und irgendwie Wohnungskram dahinstellen.
Also erst war es ein altes Schwimmbad. Erzähl doch mal ganz von Anfang an.
Ganz von Anfang an. Es war halt ein altes Schwimmbad und das wurde halt irgendwann verkauft von der Stadt, weil die halt irgendwie das Schwimmbad nicht mehr irgendwie maintainen wollte. Und die Gegend hier war zu dem Zeitpunkt halt eher noch so einigermaßen abgerockt. Also wir sind hier relativ nah an Mitte dran. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war es noch eher so eine, naja, also eher ziemlich abgerockte Gegend. Und dann hat er das gekauft und hat aber gewartet. Also der hat halt noch nicht gleich losgebaut, sondern da gab es irgendwie dann noch so ein bisschen Häseln mit Baugenehmigung und so weiter. Und dann waren da halt so Künstler drin, wir waren drin mit der Raumfahrtagentur. Dann haben die da Partys gefeiert, ziemlich lange, also ziemlich umfänglich. Und irgendwie haben wir dann schon immer darauf gewartet, dass es halt irgendwie, es fing dann halt schon so in der Umgebung so ein bisschen einfach kalt zu riechen, so da tauchten so die ersten Hipster-Läden auf, so. Und aber immer noch, also die Gegend ist jetzt halt nun nicht besonders posh hier, sondern. Und dann aber genau ist halt genau dieses passiert. Dann ist die Ertragslücke groß genug geworden. Und dann gab es halt so eine komische Abfolge von, dann gab es irgendwie so eine anonyme Anzeige. Und dann wurde die Nutzungsuntersage für das gesamte Gebäude passierte. Und wir dann durften ja nicht weiter Party machen. Wir sind auch rausgeflogen, die ganzen Künstler sind rausgeflogen. Jetzt haben wir es platt gemacht und jetzt stellen die da irgendwie Studentenapartements für 6500 Euro den Quadratmeter hin.
Also Studenten machen wir mal in Erkforz an der Stelle.
Ja, in Erkforz Studenten, ja genau. Das ist halt genau in dem Augenblick passiert, wo die Gegend attraktiv wurde, so gegenüber halt die Gerichtshilfe, so halt mit irgendwie lauter Künstlern und irgendwie interessanten Locations drinnen. Also dieses, dass das Viertel attraktiv wurde, ist ja durchaus eine Voraussetzung dafür, dass die Attraktlücke groß wird, oder? Oder wie ist da der Zusammenhang?
Also in dem konkreten Beispiel würde ich auch sagen, der hat zu lange gewartet, weil die Ertragslücke noch nicht groß genug war, weil als er es gekauft hat, hätte er vielleicht einen Neubau machen können und hätte ihn maximal für acht oder neun Euro vermieten können, weil mehr kriegt man in der Gegend nicht. Und er hat gewartet und gewartet. Und jetzt, wir haben uns ja vorhin die Broschüre von dem Investment angeguckt, jetzt werden da Micro-Apartment für 22 Euro pro Quadratmeter angeboten. Die sind so 19 Quadratmeter groß, sodass man dann da, weiß nicht, irgendwie 430, 450 Euro bezahlen soll für so eine sozusagen gestylte Mini-Bude. Und da, würde ich sagen, hat er lang genug gewartet, weil vor fünf und auch vor zehn Jahren wäre natürlich niemand bereit gewesen, irgendwie in was auch immer einer Ecke von Wedding 22 Euro pro Quadratmeter zu bezahlen. Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, diejenigen, an die sich das richtet, also diese wieder Airquot-Studierenden, die da beworben werden sollen, die von ihren Eltern dieses Micro-Apartment bekommen sollen, ziehen die hier hin, weil es im Wedding nach Kaffee riecht und weil hier Club-Marte am Kiers zu kaufen ist? Oder ziehen die hier hin? Und so ist ja auch diese Werbebroschüre aufgebaut, weil man ihnen sagt, ihr kriegt in zentraler Lage sowieso keine andere günstige Wohnung. Selbst ein WG-Zimmer kostet 450 Euro inzwischen. Und dann könnt ihr auch gleich hier richtig investieren und habt euren eigenen Mini-Palast. So und das heißt, dass im Wedding so eine Projekte inzwischen realisiert werden, hat meines Erachtens mehr mit der allgemeinen Wohnungsmarktentwicklung in Berlin zu tun, dass diese hohen Preise inzwischen hier realisiert werden können. Und hat für die konkrete Zuzugsentscheidung relativ wenig mit dem Umfeld zu tun. Und diese Überlagerung, dass diese ganzen Hipster und selbst organisierten Läden und Büchercafés und Lesebühnen und was so immer in diesen Frühphasen der Gentrification als so typisches Pioniermerkmal beschrieben wird, das ist sozusagen keine Ursache, aber es hat dieselben Gründe. Also der Grund ist nämlich, dass es diese jahrelange Desinvestition gab. Das heißt, es gibt viel Leerstand. Wenn ich da irgendwas anmiete, dann ist es billig. Da kann ich mir mein Atelier, meine Werkstatt, was auch immer sozusagen einrichten, ohne dass ich gleich eine riesige Miete bezahlen muss. Und die gleichen Gründe, nämlich dass das so einen niedrigen Ausgangspreis hat, der macht es für Investoren zum Schließen der Ertragslücke attraktiv. Also diese niedrige Ausgangswerte ist für Investoren wie auch für Pioniere und Zwischennutzer gleichermaßen attraktiv.
Okay, um die Frage anders zu formulieren, wie groß ist der Anteil der sozikulturellen Attraktivität eines Viertels an der Ertragslücke?
Ich glaube, dass das ist...
Also du meinst, wir müssen uns da nicht allzu viel schlechtes gewissen haben?
Man muss sich da kein schlechtes...
Du bist nicht schuld.
Du wirst auch mal eine gute Aussage für so einen Brotag.
Nee, aber sozusagen Immobilienwerbung funktioniert ja vielfältig. Also die erklären dir sozusagen in ihrer einen Broschüre, dass es nirgends so eine gute Verkehrsanbindung gibt wie hier. Die erklären dir gleichzeitig, wenn das Dachgeschoss zum doppelten Preis vermietet wird, dass es nur dieses eine Dachgeschoss gibt, was eine extrem gute Belichtung hat. Also das heißt, in den Vermarktungsstrategien von Immobilien wird immer darauf orientiert, ein knappes Gut, also ein ohnehin schon knappes Gut, noch weiter zu verknappen, indem ich irgendwelche Extra-Qualitäten da hinein dichte. So und da, wo es tatsächlich wenig objektive Extra-Kriterien gibt, da gehe ich sogar dahin und sage, dass es ein ganz lebendiges Viertel ist und dass hier auch schon mal jemand mit einer Rastallocke vorbeigekommen ist und dass es gegenüber drei Cafés gibt. Aber das ist ja kein objektives Lagemerkmal und wir sind... Das ist vielleicht ein Unterschied auch zur Situation von vor zehn Jahren oder zwölf oder 15 Jahren in Berlin inzwischen so weit, dass das, was wir uns als Gentrification bezeichnen, also dieses ökonomische Schließen von Ertragslücken, das ist ja ortsunspezifisch. Also das erfasst den ganzen Innenstadtbezirk. Ich wohne ja selber in Moabit, also einem anderen Westberliner Stadtteil. Da sozusagen werden ähnliche Preise aufgerufen, wie ihr sie hier aus dem Wedding beschreibt. Und da fehlt diese ganze subkulturelle Einbettung völlig. Also da überspringt man quasi die Pionierphase der Gentrification. Und ich glaube, man überspringt die nicht, sondern es sind einfach zwei voneinander unabhängige Prozesse, die sich gar keine notwendige Voraussetzung haben. Es ist gar keine notwendige Voraussetzung. Ja, und wenn wir international schauen, in Istanbul ist Gentrification mit einem Abrissbagger vollzogen worden. Da hat man ganze Roma-Siedlungen abgerissen, weil man wusste, wenn wir dort jetzt Neubau an die Stellen setzen mit einem staatlichen Wohnungsunternehmen, dann machen wir die Rendite des Jahrhunderts. Und das heißt, da hat niemand gesagt, die Roma-Kinder machen aber lustige Musik oder die kochen den besten Kaffee, den es hier gibt. Also da ist Gentrification mit einem Abrissbagger organisiert worden. Ja, oder so. Und das heißt, wir haben, wenn wir von diesen kulturellen Aufwertungen und dieser tragischen Figur der Hipster-Pioniere sprechen, also die erst was schön machen und dann selber sich das nicht mehr leisten können, also da ist so ein im Prinzip ein Oberflächenphänomen beschrieben worden, was vor allen Dingen in der deutschen Diskussion um Gentrification quasi ein Eigenleben entwickelt hat, was es sozusagen in anderen Kontexten kaum gibt. Also ich hab auch viele Kollegen, die in amerikanischen Städten oder in englischen Städten Gentrification untersuchen. Und die kommen immer auch mit diesem Konzept, also das ist Soziologie hier in Deutschland, von da kommen die Pioniere und dann kommen die echten Gentrifierer. Das verstehen die überhaupt nicht. Also dass wir diese komische Einteilung haben. Also weil da gibt es auch Gentrification, die mit Künstlern argumentiert oder die Künstler sozusagen so als Vorhut irgendwo hinschickt. Aber das ist sozusagen nicht als so eine Art natürlicher Ablaufprozess von Phasen konzipiert.
Also kann man sagen, Korrelation statt Kausatzung.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal eine interessante Erkenntnis. Du sprachst gerade von Phasen. Gibt es diese Phasen und wenn ja, wie sehen die aus? Also jetzt mein Ansatz aus ökonomische Phasen. Weil ich denke, so Phasen zu beobachten, aber ich gucke mir das ja nur so oberflächlich an.
Nein, wir haben ja die Voraussetzungsphase schon kennengelernt. Das ist erst mal die Desinvestition. Also ich muss sozusagen aus einer immobilienwirtschaftlichen Sicht so ein Viertel erst mal runterkommen lassen. Abwerten und erst sozusagen diese Abwertung ist die Voraussetzung, dass ich so einen wirklichen Ertragssprung realisieren kann. Und die Abwertung bringt, das haben wir auch schon kennengelernt. Jetzt mit sich, dass die Bausubstanz sozusagen nicht auf modernem Standard ist und auch die Mieten relativ gering sein können. Und dann ist es häufig damit verbunden, dass dann eben die, die sich nichts anderes in der Stadt leisten können, genau in diesen Vierteln wohnen. So und das ist die eine Voraussetzung. Und dann gibt es eine Phase, die ich als eine Phase der Eigentümerwechsel beschreiben würde und das, was wir in fast allen Gentrification-Gebieten beobachten, ist, dass die Eigentümertypen, die sozusagen die Desinvestition, also dieses Einsparen von Ausgaben bei geringen Mieteinnahmen als Geschäftsmodell haben, die sind häufig in ihrer Wirtschaftsstruktur jetzt gar nicht in der Lage, ein riesen Investment zu realisieren. Also weil im Prinzip ist das so ein klassisches Zinshausprojekt, wo ich sage, ich habe hier irgendwann mal oder in der Familie wurde irgendwann mal in dieses Haus investiert, ich spar mir jetzt die Ausgaben und kassiere Jahr für Jahr aus dieser Substanz oder Monat für Monat über die Mietzahlung aus der Substanz irgendeinen Ertrag, von dem ich mehr oder weniger gut leben kann oder den ich für was anderes benutze. Und wenn du so eine Wirtschaftsstruktur hast, in den Wohnungsforschungsstudien dazu hat man immer von den inaktiven Eigentümern gesprochen. Die sind gar nicht die, die sagen, oh, ich könnte hier von 4 Euro auf 12 Euro pro Quadratmeter Miete hochgehen. Ich bräuchte bloß jetzt einen Kredit von einer halben Million und könnte das hier umbauen. So, wo sollen die das denn hernehmen? Ja, und die haben auch gar keine Strukturerfahrung, um so einen Umbau oder eine Modernisierung zu realisieren. Und das sind häufig Kleineigentümer, das heißt also welche, die ein, zwei oder drei Häuser häufig lange im Familienbesitz hatten. Und die prägen sozusagen diese Struktur und die Voraussetzung dafür, dass dann tatsächlich Ertragsrückenschließung realisiert wird, ist eigentlich, dass ein ökonomisch potenter Eigentümer kommt. Und ich habe ja ganz viele von diesen Mieterinitiativen in Berlin, die sich gegen Verdrängung und Modernisierung und Umwandlung und so zur Wehr setzen. Also unglaublich viele verschiedene Geschichten, die die erzählen. Und es gibt sozusagen einen Ankerpunkt, der in all den Geschichten vorkommt. Und es ist immer der Satz so, und dann kam der neue Eigentümer. Also alle Verdrängungsgeschichten, oder fast alle Verdrängungsgeschichten in Berlin fangen eigentlich damit an. Und dann kam der neue Eigentümer. So, und was ist der neue Eigentümer? Das ist jemand, der bewusst in einem Gebiet, wo es eine Ertragslücke gibt, ein Grundstück kauft. Ja, das sehen wir dann an den Statistiken zu steigenden Grundstückspreisen. Was ist so ein Grundstückspreis? Wie kommt der zustande? Ist das irgendwas Reales? Nee, der kommt zustande, weil er die Ertragserwartung spiegelt, die der Käufer vermutet in diesem Grundstück. Also ich bin nur bereit, einen hohen Preis für ein Grundstück zu bezahlen, wenn ich tatsächlich damit rechne, dass ich kurz oder lang dieses Geld wieder reinkriege, sogar mitten im Gewinn. Und das heißt, das sicherste Indiz für einen beginnenden Gentification-Prozess ist nicht der kaffeeduft, den du hier im Wedding irgendwo gespürt hast, oder die Matebrause irgendwie im Kiosk, sondern das sicherste Zeichen für einen beginnenden Gentification-Prozess ist, dass du steigende Grundstückspreise hast und eine höhere Aktivität von Transaktionen von Grundstücken in dem Gebiet, also mit Häusern drauf und Häusern. Und dann läuft eigentlich ein ökonomischer Automatismus fast ab. Also wenn erst mal dieser hohe Preis, der die noch höhere Ertragsverwaltung spiegelt, gezahlt ist, dann gibt es natürlich einen großen ökonomischen Druck, also einen Aufwertungsdruck, das tatsächlich zu realisieren. Und wir haben so in Einzelstudien, weil es gibt darüber leider keine durchgehenden Zahlen, sozusagen auch festgestellt, dass man sieht, wenn ein höherer Preis bezahlt ist, dann rechnet sich der Käufer im Prinzip außer bei den derzeitigen Mieteinnahmen von diesen ganzen Bestandsmietern. So müsste ich jetzt zum Beispiel 37 Jahre warten, bis ich das refinanziert habe, bis ich überhaupt in eine Gewinnspanne komme. Und kein Investor in der Welt will sozusagen in Zeiten, wo du schnelles Geld an Aktien oder sonst wo verdienen kannst, 37 Jahre warten. Und der Weg, nicht 37 Jahre zu warten, ist im Moment relativ simpel. Du musst einfach nur die Mietverträge wechseln. Du musst von so einem alten Bestandsmietvertrag in eine Neuvermietungsmiete dich hochzoomen, weil die Ertragslücke enorm ist. Kannst du im Wedding das Doppelte, teilweise das Dreifache kassieren. Und da sieht man, dass dieser Aufwertungsdruck oder meinetwegen der Refinanzierungsdruck für die bereits bezahlte Ertragserwartung, dass der dazu führt oder notwendigerweise dazu führen muss, dass eine Verdrängung stattfindet. Weil beides ist nicht unter einen Hut zu kriegen. Ich kann nicht sagen, ich will die ganzen Altmeter hier lassen und dann sollen die weiter ihre 5,50 Euro pro Quadratmeter zahlen. Aber ich will mein Investment refinanziert wissen. Und das ist der Punkt, wo ich sage, Verdrängung wird zu einer notwendigen Voraussetzung für das Geschäftsmodell, was sich hier etabliert.
Also was ich ja häufiger so sehe, also noch mal kurz auf diese Phasen zurückzukommen, ist ja, dass es dann durchaus auch so eine Konsolidierungsphase gibt. Also das ist halt dann irgendwie so der, was weiß ich, irgendwie so hier Berlin so typisch irgendwie, Häuser waren bei der KWV, wurden rückübertragen, also die Ostberliner kommunale Wohnungsverwaltung, die ja also diese Desinvestitionen auf völlig neue Höhen getrieben hat. Dann wurden die halt zum Teil rückübertragen oder zum Teil von der Stadt halt irgendwie, ja, irgendwie so halb verkauft oder so. Und jedenfalls waren die dann häufiger die Häuser in den Händen von irgendwelchen, keine Ahnung, welche westdeutschen Ärzte oder sowas, also die so Bürgertum, die dann halt da so ein bisschen überlegt haben, ob sie da was mitmachen, aber festgestellt haben, es ist viel zu teuer.
Ich habe mir mal den Fachbegriff dafür sagen lassen von einem westdeutschen Immobilienhai.
Zahnwald.
Zahnwald ist das Klientel, was diese Art von Investitionen getätigt hat und das dann irgendwie als Altersvorsorge sieht.
Genau. Und die haben dann aber irgendwann gesehen, okay, sie können jetzt irgendwie die Luxussanierung nicht stemmen, weil sie nicht genug Kredit dafür kriegen oder nicht aufnehmen wollen. Und also zumindest so, was ich so beobachte. Und verkaufen dann häufig an irgendwelche ausländischen oder sonstige Investoren.
An Haie.
Nein, nicht unbedingt. Also teilweise auch Leute, die halt einfach nur irgendwie ihr Geld wegparken wollten. Und dann gibt es aber noch so diese, wo die dann so Großkonglomerate verkaufen, so diese ganze Blogs da in Prenzlauer Berg, wo die dann so zusammen aggregieren. So und wo also oder diese so hier so diese, diese amerikanische Investments Fonds, die dann halt so gleich hunderttausende von Wohnungen deutschlandweit kaufen und so. Das scheint noch mal so eine neue Effektivitätssteigerungsphase zu sein, oder?
Na ich, sind glaube ich. Also wird es als zwei verschiedene Prozesse beschreiben. Aber was ganz, ganz interessant ist, also dass du im Prinzip für Prenzlauer Berg, das ist ja sozusagen das Ostberliner Musterbeispiel für so eine Gentrification, die schon in den 90ern auch angefangen hat. Also das erste Gebiet, wo wir überhaupt Gentrification gesagt haben, glaube ich. Und da sieht man tatsächlich, dass es so eine schrittweise Veränderung der Eigentümerstruktur gibt. Klar, zum Anfang kann man sagen, so das ist ostdeutschlandweiten Phänomen gewesen. Ehemals staatlich zwangsverwaltete Altbauten werden es rückübertragen. Rückübertragung hieß ja damals, ich suche die Erben von denen, die vor dem Krieg im Besitz dieser Häuser waren und gebe sie denen zurück. Da sollte ja historische Gerechtigkeit geschaffen werden mit dieser Restitution. Das Problem war, dass man relativ schnell festgestellt hat, also diese Erben gibt es gar nicht immer so eindeutig. Da hast du viele strittige Fragen, was ist jetzt mit so einem Haus, das war in jüdischem Besitz, ist dann arisiert worden und dann sozusagen, wer soll das jetzt zurückkriegen? Also von der DDR oder vielleicht sogar noch von den Russen. 45 bis 48 enteignet. Also wer ist jetzt der rechtmäßige Besitzer, der Ariseur, die jüdische Familie? Haben die überhaupt Erben? Wo finde ich die? Also sozusagen, also schwierige Gemengelade. Und häufig hat es dazu geführt, dass diese Grundstücke dann an die Erben weitergegeben worden. Die, wenn das dann geklärt war, in der Regel eine Erbengemeinschaft waren. Also das ist ja auch klar. In 60 Jahren gibt es sozusagen nicht den Einzelerben, sondern das sind dann häufig auch verstreut auf den Kontinenten der Erde 65 oder 33 Erbteile. So und jetzt versucht man mit 65 oder 33 Leuten in verschiedenen Ländern, die außer, dass sie Erben von diesem Haus sind, häufig auch nichts Gemeinsames haben, die Verwaltung eines kaputten Hauses in Prenzlauer Berg zu organisieren. Sagen die, also willst du dafür verantwortlich sein oder soll das der Onkel machen? Wie teilen wir uns die Kosten? Was, da gibt es auch Auflagen, wir müssen jetzt sanieren. Die Miete ist ganz gering. Das Rationalste, was diese Erbengemeinschaften machen konnten, war, die Häuser zu verkaufen, weil man das Geld aus dem Verkauf, das kann man unter 33 Erben aufteilen, während die Verantwortung für den Altbau in Ostberlin, den kann man nicht fair teilen. Das heißt innerhalb von im Durchschnitt neun Monaten nach der Restitution sind alle Häuser verkauft worden. Das heißt, es gab so eine Art doppelte Privatisierung, also erst mal die staatliche Privatisierung von der Zwangsverwaltung an die Erben und dann den Verkauf an ökonomisch-rationale Eigentümer. Eine Professionalisierung der Eigentümerstruktur. Und dann fällt etwas auf, das ist nämlich in den ersten Jahren der Sanierung, da waren es noch gar nicht die Zahnwälder, sondern da hießen die alle Wohnungsbau, Entwicklungs-GmbH oder Immobilien, Goldgrund, GBR, nicht mal KG und das waren in der Regel Leute, die Häuser gekauft haben, die wussten, Prenzlauer Berg ist ein Sanierungsgebiet, hier kriege ich Fördermittel. Und wer einmal im Stadtentwicklungsbereich einen Förderantrag gesehen hat, der weiß, das ist nichts, was irgendwelche Zahnärzte und Anwälte so nebenher machen, sondern so einen Förderantrag, der setzt eine hochprofessionalisierte Struktur voraus. An Immobilienwirtschaftlicher Expertise muss ständig mit diesen Ämtern, mit der zuständigen Förderbank sprechen, muss diese Businesspläne können. Das heißt, es ist ein eigenes Geschäftsfeld. Und wir sehen in der Zeit, dass die Rahmenbedingungen der Stadterneuerung, nämlich Förderung, 60 Prozent aller Sanierungsmaßnahmen wurden mit öffentlichen Geldern gefördert. Also diese Rahmenbedingungen bestimmen, welche Eigentümer dominieren, nämlich diejenigen, die mit diesen Rahmenbedingungen am besten zurechtkommen. Und da hast du diese Firmen und die haben dann soziale Stadterneuerung gemacht. Mit all diesen Programmen sind so diese ersten Sanierungen bis 96, 97, die aus heutiger Sicht nicht besonders schön aussehen. Aber mit langfristigen, günstigen Mietverträgen versehen waren Sozialplanverfahren. Und dann passiert was, nämlich die Vorboten der Berliner Finanzkrise melden sich an. Und man sagt, man kann sich jetzt diese teuren Sanierungsprogramme nicht mehr leisten. Und ab Mitte der 90er Jahre reduziert sich drastisch das Fördergeld für die soziale Stadterneuerung. Stattdessen ist es der Zeitraum, wo es von 96 bis 98, 99 die sogenannte Sonder-AFA, Sonderabschreibungsbedingungen, die nur für Ostdeutschland galten, die eigentlich die Reindustrialisierung vorantreiben sollten, aber auch für den Wohnungsbereich ausgedehnt wurden. Und mit diesen Sonderabschreibungen konntest du innerhalb von acht Jahren dein gesamtes Investment zurückbekommen als Steuerabschreibung.
Steuerabschreibung, okay.
Und in dem Moment, wo es sozusagen ein Steuerabschreibungsmodell gab, waren diese großen Firmen, die zwar Fördergelder handhaben konnten, aber die hatten gar nicht so viel Steuergelder, die sie abschreiben konnten. Dann ist es plötzlich interessant geworden für die Zahnärzte, Anwälte, sonstigen Gruppen, die viel Steuern sparen wollten. So, und dann hast du eine Phase, in der diese ganzen typischen westdeutschen Zahnwälde, Prenzlauer Berg unter sich aufteilen von dieser Steuerersparnis.
Die Häuser sanieren?
Die Häuser sanieren. Das ist die intensivste Bauphase, weil die nämlich damals gezwungen waren. Also wer zu spät angefangen hat, konnte sozusagen nicht mehr den ganzen Steuerersparnis realisieren. Also die waren unter totalem Zeitdruck.
Das war so Ende der 90er oder was?
Ende der 90er. Möglichst schnell, möglichst viel zu verbauen und möglichst viel Steuern zu sparen. Unter diesen Bedingungen gab es sozusagen was, was wir uns heute häufig wünschen würden. Es gab diese sogenannten Miet-Obergrenzen. Die galt damals, die wurden in den Bezirken festgelegt und man hat diesen Steuerspar-Modernisierern im Prinzip gesagt, du kriegst deine Genehmigung, du musst dir nur unterschreiben, dass die Miete nach der Modernisierung immer noch bei 5 oder 6 Euro oder weiss nicht, damals D-Mark wahrscheinlich gekappt wird auf einem extrem niedrigen Niveau, würde heute niemand mehr machen. Und die haben das alle unterschrieben, weil sie eine andere Motivation haben. Weil es gar nicht darum ging, aus irgendwelchen Mieteinnahmen und Mieterträgen Geld zu wirtschaften, sondern es ging nur darum, möglichst schnell diese Steuern zu verbrennen. So und das heißt, das war auch wieder für ein bestimmtes Klientel der richtige Moment und dann sind diese Steuerabschreibungsmöglichkeiten spätestens mit dem Jahr 2000 dann sozusagen abgeschlossen, die waren nicht mehr zu realisieren. Fördergelder gab es auch nicht mehr. Das heißt also weder für diese häufig in GBRs zusammengeschlossenen Anwälte und Zahnärzte war es ein Modell, noch für die klassischen Wohnungsunternehmen, die Fördergelder akquiriert haben, sondern dann kommt die Phase der Umwandlungsmodernisierung. Dann kommen wieder eher professionelle, aber klein agierende Wohnungsunternehmen, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, Mietwohnungen und Eigentumswohnungen umzuwandeln und zu verkaufen. Das sieht man auch an den steigenden Zahlen von Umwandlungen und Eigentumswohnungen. Und die hatten ein relativ mieterfeindliches Modell, weil die gesagt haben, wir beginnen die Modernisierung erst, wenn wir für die Hälfte der Wohnung in dem Haus einen potenziellen Käufer haben. Das heißt, die sind damals durch die Häuser gegangen, völlig kaputtes Altbaugebäude mit Ofenheizung, Außenklo. Sie haben Pläne gemacht, wie das hier aussehen könnte, wenn sie saniert haben und sind dann mit diesen Broschüren sozusagen hausieren gegangen und haben gefragt, willst du hier nicht eine Wohnung kaufen? Wenn 50 Prozent der Wohnungen verkauft waren, also als Kaufoption, dann sind die erst zur Bank gegangen, haben sich das Geld geholt, um die Modernisierung zu organisieren. Und es hatte aber eine dramatische Verdrängungskonsequenz, weil ja völlig klar war, mindestens die Hälfte der Mieter in dem Haus wohnt jetzt in einer Wohnung, die ist auf dem Papier schon verkauft. Das heißt also, der Druck, diese Mieter vor die Tür zu setzen, war extrem groß, weil sonst dieses ganze Geschäft platzt. Und das ist so das Zeitalter, wo es vielleicht so aus dem Bekanntenkreis so immer mal Geschichten gibt, dass jemals 30, 40, 50.000 Euro geboten wurde für einen Auszug. Ja. Und das ist sozusagen eingepreist in diesen Sachen. Ich habe inzwischen auch so mit Investoren mal sprechen können, die so eine Umwandlungsstrategien fahren und die rechnen im Durchschnitt. Das ist in ihren Businessplänen oder wenn die zur Bank gehen und da Kredite beantragen. Auch mit Festgeldern, die rechnen 200 Euro pro Quadratmeter, sozusagen Auszugskosten. So und naja, die kannst du als Prämie im Durchschnitt, dann sind 20.000 für 100 Quadratmeter. Oder du kannst auch sagen, die Omas erschrecke ich erstmal mit einem Rechtsanwält, die Familien unterstütze ich mit einer Umzugshilfe und den Dritten biete ich irgendwas anderes. Und wenn dann sozusagen noch eine kleine Gruppe übrig bleibt, dann kann ich die Letzten dann auch mit relativ viel Geld abkaufen. Und das ist aber ein völlig anderes Modell. Und das, was ich da faszinierend finde, das sind ja im Prinzip so 15 Jahre im Prenzlauer Berg, die so als Phasen da durchlaufen werden, dass man deutlich sieht, dass es eben überhaupt nichts Natürliches und keine festen Konstanten in der Stadtentwicklung gibt, sondern dass ich mit veränderten Rahmenbedingungen, vor allen Dingen den veränderten ökonomischen Rahmenbedingungen, sozusagen die Spielregeln ändere und gleich die Akteure mit verändere. Das bringt mich jetzt dahin so, was ist das heute hier mit diesen großen Fonds und Investitionen so? Und da ist es glaube ich tatsächlich so, dass es noch mal eine Zuspitzung von Verwertungsstrategien gibt, die das Agieren auf Wohnungsmärkten fast ausschließlich aus einer Perspektive einer Finanzanlage erklären und immer weniger damit zu tun haben, tatsächlich aus der Bausubstanz irgendetwas herausholen zu wollen. Wir sprechen so ein bisschen von, also auch international wird es ja beobachtet, so einer Finanzialisierung der Wohnungswirtschaft. Und das, was sich hinter diesen großen Fonds, also wo man sich fragt, also was sollen jetzt große amerikanische Fonds, die sozusagen sowohl in der Chemieindustrie als auch in chinesischen Containerhäfen investieren? Warum kaufen die sich jetzt hunderttausend Wohnungen in Berlin oder Deutschland? Das ist sozusagen nicht naheliegend. Wohnungswirtschaftliches Geschäft, ja, aber für Finanzanleger gibt es ja gar keine naheliegenden Branchen, sondern ich schaue sozusagen, wo kann ich eine renditeträchtige Anlageform platzieren? Und das ist für die im Moment der Wohnungsmarkt, der dann als, weiß nicht, Betongold oder sicherer Hafen oder was auch immer Vorteile aufweist, die andere Anlageform nicht haben. Und wenn wir uns das, weil das auch hier im Neubau-Projekten, die bei euch hier vor der Tür dann stattfindet, das ist eine völlige Umkehrung des Verhältnisses von Wohnungswirtschaft und Finanzwirtschaft. Also der klassische Weg war, ich hab dann Wohnungsunternehmen, die haben einen Plan in den nächsten 30 Jahren mit mehr oder weniger teuren Mietwohnungen oder Eigentumswohnungen Geld zu verdienen, gehen mit diesem Businessplan zur Bank und sagen, liebe Bank, du musst uns das finanzieren. Wir haben hier richtig gut durchgerechnet. Wir kriegen das Geld alles wieder und dann finanziert die Bank. So heute, Finanzialisierung heißt, ich habe ein Finanzinstitut oder einen Fonds und sage, ich habe hier einen Haufen Geld, das muss ich irgendwo anbringen. Ich suche mir jetzt mal einen Bauträger, der mir vielleicht ein Haus baut damit. Das heißt also Mittel- und Zweckrelationen zwischen Wohnungswirtschaft und Finanzwirtschaft drehen sich sozusagen einmal im Kreis. Wir wundern uns dann als Leute, die wir in der Stadt wohnen, dass die Ergebnisse davon sich immer weiter von dem entfernen, was wir als Bewohner einer Stadt uns wirklich wünschen, was man wirklich dringend braucht. Ich glaube, selbst wenn man die Studierenden, wieder in Anführungszeichen, die hier beworben werden für diese Micro-Appartments, wenn man die alle fragen würde, wollt ihr gerne auf neunzehneinhalb Quadratmeter wohnen für 450 Euro? Das wäre für niemanden sozusagen die präferierte Wohnform. Oder wollt ihr lieber ein WG-Zimmer mit der dreifachen Größe haben? Zum selben Preis. Und das heißt, da geht es an den Bedürfnissen vorbeigeplant.
Das heißt also, um es noch mal kurz zu rekapitulieren, heißt das, dass so eine Phasenbetrachtung eigentlich ja nur eine Reflektion ist von dem regulatorischen Environment, also was sozusagen die Stadt versucht, irgendwie zu steuern und was dann dazu führt, dass wiederum andere Akteure halt irgendwie ins Spiel kommen. Und die aber tatsächlich auch, ja zum Teil auch parallel laufen. Also jetzt diese Umwandlung von Wohnraum zu einem tradable asset läuft ja parallel zu immer noch stattfindenden Umwandlungen zum Beispiel. Also wir haben jetzt, war doch gerade, genau das wollte ich nochmal fragen. Es gab doch gerade, in den letzten Jahren gab es doch diesen riesigen Rush, wo man keine Notartermine überhaupt mehr bekam, weil die alle mit diesen Aufteilungsgeschichten beschäftigt waren, was ich nicht so ganz verstanden habe, wie das funktioniert. Also diese Abgeschlossenheitsbescheinigung.
Das war sogar vorletztes Jahr, als die sogenannte, du hast ja vorhin schon, also Fefe nachher gefragt, die Umwandlungsverordnung eingeführt wurde, wo zumindest in den Milieuschutzgebieten, also es sind so Gebiete, die glaube ich in der Innenstadt ein Viertel der Fläche ausmachen und da war angekündigt, hier wird ab Einführung der Umwandlungsverbotsverordnung oder der Umwandlungsverordnung wird hier die Umwandlung in Eigentumswohnungen unter Genehmigungsvorbehalt gestellt. Das heißt, aus der Perspektive gab es plötzlich einen totalen Druck, möglichst viele von diesen potenziellen Umwandlungen schon zu vollziehen.
Vorher zu machen.
Vorher zu machen. Genau, aber das ist ein Effekt, den gibt es immer.
Zum Verständnis, da geht es ja darum, dass das Haus sozusagen in grundbuchlich separate Einheiten aufgeteilt wird, die man dann wiederum verkaufen kann. Aber eigentlich hat man doch als Mieter einen relativ guten Schutz vor so einer spontanen Umwandlung und Rausschmeißung oder...
Genau, also...
Also wie ist ja auch so ein Dämpfungsmechanismus, den die Stadt hier hat, ne? Wie funktioniert denn der?
Na, das ist ja, weiß nicht, wie heißt es immer hier, Kauf bricht Mietrecht nicht. Also sagt der Mieterverein oder die Mietergemeinschaft ja immer in den Broschüren, sagt, keine Angst bei Umwandlung, dein Mietvertrag hat ja Bestand. Und das Einzige, wo so eine Umwandlung in der Eigentumswohnung, eine schon bewohnte Eigentumswohnung zum Problem wird, ist, wenn die Käufer sagen, ich will die Wohnung aber selber nutzen. Das ist dann die sogenannte Eigenbedarfskündigung. Da gibt es in Berlin inzwischen, das ist die Kündigung Schutzklauselverordnung, da gibt es inzwischen so eine Schutzklausel, die sagt, wenn so ein Eigenbedarf angemeldet wird, dann hat der Mieter oder die Mieterin zehn Jahre noch einen Schutz. Also ich kann sozusagen jetzt nicht heute die Wohnung mit dem Mieter kaufen und dann gleich morgen sagen, hier jetzt einmal raus, ich will die selber nutzen, sondern muss da zehn Jahre warten, was eine relativ gute Rechtsposition erstmal ist, aber in der Regel natürlich dazu führt, dass die Uhr anfängt zu ticken. Also wenn ich weiß, in zehn Jahren muss ich hier raus und dann sind vielleicht schon drei oder vier Jahre vorbei, dann fängt das sozusagen schon an, dass man sagt, ah, suche ich mir eine andere Wohnung, ich sehe auch, dass die Mietpreise steigen, stell dir mal vor, die steigen jetzt noch weitere sechs Jahre, ist es nicht günstiger, wenn ich jetzt gleich irgendwie hier den Absprung mache, das heißt also in vielen Fällen führt es dazu, dass es eine Beschleunigung gibt. Und das heißt also, da gibt es eine Verunsicherung und dann kann natürlich in vielen Fällen der Auszug auch nochmal beschleunigt werden. Also, ich weiß nicht, was wir in den letzten zwei Jahren an einigen Stellen beobachtet haben, war zum Beispiel das Phänomen der sogenannten fiktiven Modernisierungsankündigung. Also, dass dir deine Hausverwaltung...
Was kommt denn jetzt hier?
Ja, schickt dir eine Modernisierungsankündigung. Mit allem hat ja die Regierung, irgendwie die vorletzte Regierungskoalition, glaube ich, beschlossen, energetische Sanierungen, die hier für die gesellschaftlichen Klimaschutzziele notwendig sind, die muss der Mieter und die Mieterin einfach dulden. Da gibt es keine Zustimmungspflicht und auch keine Zustimmungs-, also Ablehnungsmöglichkeiten. Das heißt, du kriegst eine Modernisierungsankündigung mit lauter energetischen Maßnahmen, irgendwie tolle neue Heizung, Fassadendämmung, neue Fenster, alles perfekt. Und das summiert sich auf eine wirklich deftige Modernisierungsumlage. Vielleicht 4,50 Euro pro Quadratmeter Mietsteigerung. Damit grenzt du dann zum Anwalt. Dein Anwalt sagt, das ist ja alles richtig korrekt. Das darf er auch alles machen. Wir könnten jetzt hier versuchen, noch soziale Härte anzubringen, aber es ist in ihrem Fall auch ein bisschen schwierig. Was macht der Mieter? Der Anwalt sagt, die Ankündigung ist formal korrekt. Geht zu Immo-Scout, sagt, ich suche Wohnung in der Nähe, zu folgenden Konditionen. Finde dann vielleicht auch eine Wohnung. Zieht da um. Weil die Mietsteigung, die angekündigt ist, kann ich mir nicht leisten. Den Stress mit so einer Baustelle will ich nicht ertragen. Die Rechtsaussichten gegen diese energetischen Sanierungsmaßnahmen werden eher als gering eingeschätzt. Dann zieht der Mieter aus, hat vergessen, seine Suchabfrage dabei Immo-Scout zu löschen, kriegt also immer noch hier alle zwei Tage die Angebote und sieht nach vier Wochen, die Wohnung, die ich eben verlassen habe, ist jetzt hier zum doppelten Preis angeboten, aber ohne Sanierung. Ja, natürlich.
Verstehe, okay.
Und das ist ein, das haben wir auch mit den Anwälten hier von den Mieterorganisationen gesprochen, es gibt für so eine Kündigung, die du ausgesprochen hast, gibt es keine Möglichkeit, am Ende noch mal nach sechs Wochen zurückzukommen, zu sagen, hier, ich bin verarscht worden. Ich bin nur ausgezogen, weil der gesagt hat, er will sanieren, er hat jetzt gar nicht saniert. Und jeder Eigentümer kann dann auch sagen, haben sich die Rahmenbedingungen verändert.
Das heißt, in so einer Situation halt lieber einfach warten, bis das Baugerüst da steht oder wie?
Das ist auch nicht schön. Also das sind ja...
Nee, aber gut, ich kann es immer noch sagen. Ich geb auf. Also ja.
Ich wollte nur dem nachhelfen, um den Umzug zu provozieren. Da gibt es wahrscheinlich verschiedene Wege. Da gibt es natürlich die klassischen Wege, die wir vorhin schon besprochen haben. Da wird dir Geld geboten oder du wirst einfach mit dämlichen Klagen und ein, zwei liegen, verfügung überhäuft, weil du irgendeine Kellertür nicht abgeschlossen hast oder abgeschlossen hast. Also da gibt es so einen juristischen Kleinkrieg häufiger, den die Leute aus solchen Häusern berichten. Und was mir da auffällt ist, dass wir eigentlich ja, was ich sage, ja viele immer so irgendwie das beste Mietrecht der Welt irgendwie verglichen jetzt mit anderen europäischen Ländern. Gibt es ja total viele Schutzinstrumente im Mietrecht. Die Grundidee dabei ist ja, dass gesagt wird, das Mietrecht soll diese widersprüchlichen Interessen von Mietern und Vermietern in der Balance irgendwie ausgleichen. Es kompliziert das Verhältnis und das Mietrecht reguliert dieses Verhältnis. Und das, was wir in diesen Aufwertungsprozessen erleben, ist, dass das Mietrecht oder einzelne Elemente des Mietrechts eigentlich nur noch genutzt werden, um das Mietverhältnis zu beenden. Also mit diesem Kleinkrieg an juristischen Instrumenten geht es häufig nicht mehr darum, das Verhältnis in irgendeiner Weise zu regulieren, damit beide Interessen, Mieter und Vermieter, gut berücksichtigt werden. Es geht eigentlich nur noch darum, das Verhältnis zu beenden. Und dafür ist das Mietrecht aber nicht geschaffen worden.
Aber dann könnte man aber auch argumentieren, dass das Mietrecht eben dieser Mitte nicht trifft, sondern zu sehr auf Seiten des Mieters ist. Und daher der Vermieter sozusagen zu solchen Mitteln greifen muss. Denn wenn seine Interessen vertreten wären, müsste er sowas nicht machen. Oder anders gesagt, wenn die Miete nicht gedeckelt wäre, wie weit die hochgehen darf, dann gäbe es ja die Grundsituation gar nicht, aus der Gentrification entsteht. Dass es überhaupt diese billigen runtergewirtschafteten Ruinen gibt. Was sagst du denn zu der These?
Erstmal zu diesem Mietrecht, also da gebe ich dir zum fernen Recht, dass je weiter die Ertragserwartung und die Leistungsfähigkeit der Mieter zur Mietzahlung auseinanderklaffen. Also wenn ich jetzt schon die Millionen für das Grundstück gezahlt habe und weiß, ich muss ja mindestens 13 Euro kassieren und der Mieter sagt aber schon 5 Euro pro Quadratmeter sind mir eigentlich zu viel, dann kann man unabhängig davon, wo das Mietrecht die Mitte trifft, und dann sagen, da ist überhaupt keine Balance für beide Seiten zu finden. Also das heißt, das Mietrecht ist dafür relativ unbrauchbar. Und je stärker die Gegensätze aufeinanderprallen, desto weniger kann das Mietrecht seine eigentliche Intention des Ausgleichs entfalten. So und das andere Argument, das hört man häufig, dass man sagt, wenn der Markt gleich freigegeben wäre, dann würde es auch keine Verdrängung geben und da würde keine Gentrification stattfinden. Aber dieser Ertragssprung, der ist ja trotzdem, also den kennen wir ja auch aus anderen Städten, also dann würde vielleicht nicht diese einfache Neuvermietung zu einem höheren Preis zuschlagen, aber einen Standardunterschied, der sozusagen würde sich schon zu Buche schlagen, also dass es Gebiete gibt, wo eine jahrelange Desinvestition zu einer schlechten Bausubstanz führt und wenn ich es aufwerte, kann ich zu einem deutlich höheren Preis vermieten. Und was mich an der Argumentation, also jetzt nicht wenn du die bringst, aber weil die ja häufig formuliert wird, tatsächlich stört, also dieses sozusagen so FDP-mäßige, jetzt soll man den freien Markt mal machen lassen, der ist ja eine völlige Illusion, also welcher freie Markt, also sozusagen der Wohnungsmarkt, jetzt auch mal von mir mit Anführungsstrichen, der sozusagen wird Jahr für Jahr mit 17 Milliarden Euro an Subjektförderung finanziert. Subjektförderung ist der Fachbegriff dafür, dass über Wohngeld oder Kosten der Unterkunft die Mieter als Sozialleistungen ausgestattet werden, eine Zahlungsfähigkeit zu erreichen, die sie aus ihrer sozialen Situation gar nicht hätten.
Also Wohngeld und sowas, ja?
Ja, genau, also du hast ein geringes Einkommen, kannst dir eigentlich in der Stadt keine Wohnung leisten zu den Preisen, die sie anbieten und ich erfinde das Wohngeld und gebe dir das Wohngeld. Es wird verkauft als eine Form der sozialen Förderung für ärmere Haushalte. Real ist es aber ja eine unmittelbare Wirtschaftsförderung für die Eigentümer, weil der Mieter hat ja von diesem Geld gar nichts, sondern das muss er ja sofort weitergeben. Und ich kann eigentlich sagen, ich gebe in Deutschland ja für 17 Milliarden Euro dafür aus, ist mehr als die Steinkohleförderung damals, glaube ich, um einen Wirtschaftskreis zu finanzieren, der sich aus den tatsächlichen Markt- und Nachfrageverhältnissen gar nicht konstituieren ließe. Und die gleichen, die sozusagen immer wieder sagen, man soll das Wohngeld erhöhen, die sagen dir in der nächsten Diskussion, kann ja der Staat zahlen. Es ist das Allerschlimmste, was man machen kann, dass man irgendwie in diese Marktmechanismen eingreift. Das ist eher das Problem. Und was wir da jetzt noch nicht drin haben, kommt dann noch dazu, ungefähr 6 bis 8 Milliarden Euro, die über die ganz normalen Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten, die du in so einer wohnungswirtschaftlichen Kalkulation hast, an Steuerverzichten vergeben werden. Wenn du das zusammenrechnest, heißt das irgendwie, der freie Markt wird mit 25 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr mit staatlichen Geldern subventioniert. Und sobald du aber sagst, dafür will ich aber auch eine Mietpreisbremse oder ein gutes Mietrecht bekommen, dann wird gesagt, darf man gar nicht so viel eingreifen.
Ist das jetzt deutschlandweit oder berlin?
Deutschlandweit.
Das ist ja schon eine krasse Zahl. Wenn man das mal umschlägt auf die Bundesländer, da wird sich ja einiges an Budgetloch mitfüllen lassen. Also ich denke mir auch, wenn man diese sozialen Kosten kann man ja auch andersrum sehen, dass du sagst, dieses hohe Niveau ermögliche ich hier erst. Das heißt, es gibt noch einen Anreiz, es sogar noch höher zu machen. Okay, also das ist ja schon einigermaßen spannend. Da stellt sich mir erstmal die Frage, gab es jemals versucht, das regulativ zu lösen? Zu sagen, wenn du ein Mietshaus besitzt, musst du also diese Desinvestitionen einfach zu verbieten? Gab es das schon mal als Versuch oder irgendwie dagegen zu steuern? Ist das überhaupt denkbar? Vielleicht bilde ich mir auch nur ein, dass man da was machen könnte.
Ich glaube, dass diese Desinvestition vor allen Dingen in den 80er Jahren das große Problem war. Wo genau in der Zeit, das kann man, glaube ich, dann noch wieder ökonomisch ganz gut einordnen, in der sich viel Geld mit dem Bau von Einfamilienhäusern am Stadtrand verdienen ließ, weil möglichst viele dorthin wollten. Das zahlungskräftige Klientel, die Innenstädte verlassen hat. Da haben fast alle Eigentümer darauf gesetzt, ich spare jetzt hier die Renovierungskosten und die Instandsetzungskosten und lasse sozusagen die Häuser verlottern. Und damals hat der Staat mit sogenannten Sanierungssatzungen gearbeitet und hat gesagt, ich lege jetzt hier fest, dass dieses Gebiet saniert werden muss. Und du lieber Eigentümer musst hier einfach mitmachen. Ach du willst nicht, du hast auch nicht das Geld, dann kannst du mir dein Grundstück geben. Würste für entschädigt. Krass, krass.
Und hat das funktioniert?
Ja klar. Also sozusagen Kreuzberg, die Sanierung, klassischer Fall mit so beruhigender Stadterneuung, sind im Prinzip für einen Zeitraum von 10, 11 Jahren im Vorfeld der beginnenden Sanierungsarbeiten, sind diese Sanierungsträger gebildet worden und haben sozusagen Grundstück für Grundstück aufgekauft und sind dabei vorgegangen, wie jetzt die Investoren, wenn sie die Mieter entschädigen. Also die Eigentümer, die ganz lange ausgehalten haben, die haben dann auch eine relativ hohe Entschädigung noch bekommen. Und wenn die dann so einen Block fertig haben, also vollständig in der Hand des Sanius sind, dann wird jetzt, jetzt organisieren wir die Stadterneuerung mit den Mietern zusammen und mit den Baufirmen. Und wenn wir damit fertig sind, dann verkaufen wir es wieder. Also um diese staatliche Maßnahme zu refinanzieren. Ja und das hat eigentlich ganz gut geklappt.
Das klingt sogar, als wenn man da unterm Strich Gewinn machen kann. Na, hat das stattgefunden oder war das eher so, wir sind froh, wenn wir hier keinen Verlust schreiben?
Du darfst nicht vergessen, dass es zu Zeiten des SPD-Immobiliensohnes war. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir Gewinne gemacht haben.
Also ich glaube, dass da viele, also sozusagen diese Sanierungsträger, das sind ja im Prinzip private Firmen, die im öffentlichen Auftrag agieren und das ist, das ist glaube ich so ein Dunstbereich.
Das ist korruptionsgeneigtes Gewerbe, würde ich sagen.
Das Abschöpfen ist in alle möglichen Richtungen. Und Bekannte von mir haben sich an Einzelhäusern die Subventionsquote der Modernisierungsmaßnahmen in Kreuzberg angeguckt und die sind zum Beispiel wirklich nur bei der Auswertung der Papiere, also wo sozusagen die dunklen Geschäfte noch nicht dabei sind und haben Häuser entdeckt, wo die Subventionsquote 130 Prozent der Maßnahmen sind.
Das Zeug von Talent, ja.
Und das ist aber im Einzelfall natürlich schwer nachzuweisen und musste halt an die Unterlagen ran. Aber grundsätzlich ist es schon möglich, einen Stadterneuerungsprozess anders zu beschreiben. Desinvestitionen ist in den USA zum Beispiel. Die haben ein völlig anderes Steuersystem. Also relativ hohe Steuern auf die Grundstücke und Gebäude. Und in dem Moment, wo so eine Desinvestitionspraxis sich etabliert, steigt, weil dein Umsatz insgesamt sinkt, die Steuerquote. Und es gibt irgendwann so einen Prozess, wo du denkst, so scheiße, also für so ein kaputtes Haus hier in der Bronx muss ich irgendwie so viel Steuern zahlen, weil die Steuern sozusagen nicht am Umsatz, sondern an dem Grundstück dranhängen. Und das heißt, da gab es dann ganz viele Grundstückseigentümer, die sagten, boah, also diese hohen Steuern, ich bin froh, wenn ich es hier weggeben kann. Oder was dort dann der Fall war, wenn die, glaube ich, drei oder vier Jahre diese Steuern nicht bezahlt haben für die Grundstücke, dann fällt das Grundstück einfach an die Stadt und die konnte es dann weiter entwickeln. Also das heißt, es gibt schon Instrumente, die dieses Desinvestieren einschränken könnten.
Das klingt eigentlich gar nicht doof, so ans Modell. Aber da haben wir jetzt eigentlich einen schönen Übergang zu der Frage, die ich am Anfang hatte. Was gibt es da eigentlich für Hebel, die so eine Regierung, sagen wir, von Berlin hat und wie gut funktionieren die?
Da hatte ich noch eine Frage zu, weil eines der Dinge, die ich jetzt sah, war, dass es zwar eine Umwandlungsmitteilung gab, also diese Aufteilungsmitteilung, aber gleichzeitig die Mitteilung, dass es nur an die Mieter verkauft werden darf.
Ja, das ist die Umwandlungsverordnung im Milieuschutzgebiet. Also, hatte ich ja gesagt, wurde eingeführt, um sozusagen die Umwandlung mit einem Vorbehalt zu stellen. Und das Interessante war ja, dass eigentlich in der Berichterstattung über diese Milieuschutzsatzung, die Umwandlungsverordnung, eigentlich so der Grundtenor in der Wahrnehmung dieses neuen Gesetzes oder der neuen Verordnung war, endlich Umwandlung im Milieuschutzgebiet ist jetzt verboten. Und war gar nicht verboten, sondern stand unter einem Genehmigungsvorbehalt. Genehmigungsvorbehalt heißt, muss geprüft werden, wird nicht einfach nur abgestempelt. Und diese Prüfung besagt, die Umwandlung ist nach wie vor möglich, und zwar an den Mieter oder an die Mieterin. Das ist so ein Entgegenkommen an die Reste von Eigentümerideologien, die es überall gibt. Dass man sagt, das ist ja auch nicht schlecht, dass wenn die Mieter ihre Wohnung kaufen, und da soll jetzt der Milieuschutz, also niemand soll aus dem Milieu verdrängt werden, nur weil er seine Wohnung nicht kaufen kann. Also so ungefähr ist das sozusagen argumentiert worden. Und dann ist ja auch gut, wenn die dann Eigentümer werden, dann bleiben die ja auch lange da, dann stärken die das Milieu, was sich hier schützen will. Und das Ganze hat aber den Haken, das ist diese Umwandlungsverordnung, das Ausnahme bei Verkauf an die Mieter, nicht genau definiert, wer wann als Mieter zählt. Also das heißt, da gibt es keinen zeitlichen Anker, der zum Beispiel sagt, der Kauf ist nur zulässig an den Mieter zum Zeitpunkt der Umwandlung.
Okay.
Sondern ich unterschreibe einfach nur, ich verkaufe das nur an den Mieter. Und jetzt könnte ich den Mieter, weil ich jetzt festgestellt habe, du lieber Mieter, wohnst jetzt hier in dieser umgewandelten Wohnung oder in der potenziell umzuwandelnden Wohnung, willst aber gar nicht oder kannst gar nicht kaufen, könnte ich auf die Idee kommen, dass ich dich jetzt vor die Tür setze und mir den Mieter suche, der dann in der Lage ist, zu kaufen.
Also zu sagen, ich verkaufe den und du musst noch mal einen Monat vorher anmieten.
Genau. So, das ist die Befürchtung. Also gibt es sozusagen noch keinen praktischen Fall.
Also ist noch nicht passiert.
Ist noch nicht passiert, aber es gab, glaube ich, im Anfang des Jahres, weil dieses Problem in Hamburg auch bekannt ist, haben Hamburg und Berlin eine Bundesratsinitiative gestartet, um diese Lücke in die Umwandlungsverordnung zu schließen. Und sind quasi von allen anderen Bundesländern da verlacht worden, weil die gesagt haben, wir wissen nicht mal, was eine Umwandlung ist. Und irgendwie Mieter haben wir ja auch nicht. Also sozusagen, die sind mit dem Problem nicht klargekommen. Und das ist sozusagen dann vielleicht auch wegen politischer Mehrheiten im Bundesrat. Also ist es dann nicht durchgekommen, diese Reform, obwohl es sinnvoll gewesen wäre.
Die Städte müssen jetzt warten, bis das vor Gericht landet oder wie?
Na entweder so und kann das natürlich provozieren. Man könnte jetzt hier in Berlin sagen, wir haben ja in vier oder fünf Bezirken, vielleicht zu hören, mehr diese Milieuschutzgebiete. Und man könnte jetzt schon relativ deutlich sagen, die Staatsverwaltung gibt mal einen Hinweis, wie die Umwandlungsverordnung in Berlin anzuwenden ist. Und es wäre relativ einfach, dass man dachte, also wir verstehen den Verkauf an Mieter so, dass damit der Mieter zum Zeitpunkt der Umwandlung gemeint ist oder der Mieter zum Zeitpunkt der Festlegung des Milieuschutzgebietes.
Also weit in der Vergangenheit sozusagen dann ja. Aber wer würde trotzdem darauf hinauslaufen, dass man sich da ein paar Jahre vor Gericht oberstreitet?
Genau.
Am Ende, weil dann könnten die Mestoren ja dann wieder um zu BGH und so weiter. Und das könnte noch weiter dauern dann. Okay, ich verstehe. Es klingt so ein bisschen so, als wären diese Regulatorien, also um den Bogen zurückzufinden, so was hat dann die Stadt dafür Hebel, als wäre das ganz schönes Gebasteln so. Also als wäre es nicht irgendwie, jetzt könnte man nicht mal sagen, okay, das ist jetzt das, wie wir das machen.
Genau, und es gibt ja so klassische Beispiele mit, wir haben ja diese Mietpreisbremse, die ist ja auch eingeführt worden. Dann hat man jetzt in Berlin fast zwei Jahre Guilty und die sagt, und das wäre eigentlich für Berlin wirklich ein gutes Instrument gewesen, bei einer Neuvermietung einer Wohnung darf die Miete nicht höher als 15 Prozent über den Mietspiegelwert, wo der ortsüblichen Vergleichsmiete liegt. Dann würde man diese ganze Ertragslückenschließung einfach durch eine Neuvermietung, die hätte man ja reduzieren können. Und jetzt gab es Studien, die gefragt haben, wie wirkt denn die Mietpreisbremse? Und die haben nicht nur in Berlin, sondern in allen deutschen Großstädten festgestellt, zwischen 70 und 85 Prozent aller Mietangebote liegen über diesen Höchstwerten, die nach Mietpreisbremse zulässig wären. So, weil der Markt halt hergibt. So, und dann stellt man das fest und fragt sich, warum macht denn niemand, dass diese gerade eingeführte Mietpreisbremse eingehalten wird? Und dann kannst du zum Bezirksamt oder zum Senat gehen und dann sagen die dir, wir sind dafür gar nicht zuständig, der Mieter, der hat ein Klagerecht. Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt sozusagen...
Welcher Mieter, der alte oder der neue?
Der neue Mieter, der hat ein Klagerecht. Und es gibt jetzt auch inzwischen zwei, drei Fälle, wo Mieter...
Wie ist es? Angebot alleine reicht nicht? Also wenn ich sage, okay...
Okay, ich muss mich erst verarschen lassen und dann kann ich klagen? Genau.
Und wenn du dich nicht verarschen lässt, kriegst du ja die Wohnung nicht. Also wenn du im Bewerbungsgespräch in Konkurrenz mit 30 anderen sagst, na hör mal zu, diese Wohnung ist doch hier viel zu teuer. Nach Mietpreisbremse, dann kriegst du die Wohnung ja nicht. Das heißt, du musst dich da in der Konkurrenz durchsetzen. Dein erster Akt im neuen Mietverhältnis muss sein, deinen Vermieter zu verklagen.
Ja super.
So und deshalb machen das wenige. So und es gibt keinen sozialen behördlichen Weg dazu. Und das ist ein Prinzip, was in ganz vielen Bereichen des Mietrechts im Prinzip etabliert ist, dass man sagt, es gibt hier ein individuelles Klagerecht auf dein Mietrecht, aber es gibt keine behördliche Verantwortung dafür. Ja und wir haben auch keine Wohnungsaufsicht, wo man sagt, Vermieter müssen hier ihre Mietverträge einreichen, damit irgendeine Behörde prüft, ob...
Ich meine, es würde ja reichen, wenn die halt ein exemplarisches Klagerecht hätten und einfach Immobilien-Scout abgrasen und die mal irgendwie dagegenhalten und dann mal jeden Zehnten da rausschießen. Das wäre vollkommen ausreichend, um das Recht durchzusetzen.
Aber es gibt nicht mal ein Verbandsklagerecht, also nicht mal der Mieterverein könnte solche Fälle sammeln und klagen, sondern nur der einzelne Mieter. Also Mietrecht ist ein bürgerliches Individualrecht.
Musstest du oder hat es jemand verkackt? Also hat die FDP reingegriffen.
Ja.
Ohne jetzt die FDP rausziehen zu wollen, versteht schon.
Nee, aber es gibt glaube ich keine...
Es ist in der Rente bei Mietrecht, ja?
Keine große politische Mehrheit für ein behördliches Eingreifen. Da sind wir wieder so ein bisschen am Anfang, wie viel soll der Staat regulieren. Und das Zweite, und da würde es ja noch absurder werden, haben sich Vermieter inzwischen auch, sind sich vielleicht irgendeines Klagerisikos bewusst. Und seit es diese ersten Klagen gibt, ist ein Anzeigenmodul oder ein Anzeigensegment bei Immo Scout und den anderen Wohnungsanbietern massiv gestiegen. Nämlich das der möblierten Wohnung. Weil die Mietpreisbremse ist sozusagen für die normale Wohnung. Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ich habe aber eine möblierte Wohnung, weil hier ist ja auch irgendwie schon ein Küchenschrank drin oder hier steht ein Hocker irgendwie im Flur, dann gibt es für diese Möblierung kein Maßstab, wie hoch der Aufpreis für die Möblierung ist. Sondern der wird sozusagen dann zwischen Mieter und Vermieter geklärt.
Aber das klingt doch wieder nach mit Absicht verkackt. Tut mir leid, das klingt nicht wie versehen, sondern wie ich habe Freunde in der Immobilienbranche.
Kann man sagen, es gab einen ziemlich großen Lobby-Einfluss beim Schreiben der Mietpreisbranche. Aber ich glaube, dass man noch was Zweites sieht. Und das ist nämlich, dass man mit allen Versuchen, privatwirtschaftliches Gewinnstreben in rechtliche Bahnen zu lenken, immer die Fantasie anstachelt, diese Hürden, die ich da staatlicherseits aufbaue, in irgendeiner Weise zu umschiffen oder zu umgehen. Und das ist für mich deshalb eine Konsequenz darauf, dass wenn ich die tatsächlich nachhaltig statt anders entwickeln will, dass ich das eigentlich nicht in einem Kampf gegen Privateigentümer machen kann, also den ich das Soziale nicht ohne weiteres abverlangen kann und die das auch nicht wollen. Und wenn ich jetzt weiß, ich habe eigentlich ein soziales Versorgungsziel in der Stadt, was mir wichtig ist, dann sind Private gar nicht mein erster Ansprechpartner. Sondern muss ich sagen, was ist denn mit Genossenschaften, was ist mit gemeinnützigen Wohnungsunternehmen, was ist mit öffentlichen Wohnungsunternehmen, dann muss ich mir halt nicht profitorientierte Partner suchen in der Stadt. Und dann kann man jetzt sagen, gut, die sind aber nicht da und die wollen vielleicht auch keine spekulativen Preise in der Innenstadt sagen. Aber es würde meine Perspektive auf Instrumente in der Stadtentwicklung völlig verändern, wenn ich sage, das Ziel ist, dass möglichst viele von den guten Eigentümern demnächst hier dominieren. Und deshalb überlege ich mir Regeln, die vielleicht nicht unmittelbar auf die Miethöhe gehen, sondern übernehmen mir Regeln, die das Investieren in Berlin eher unattraktiv machen. Ja, und so wäre zum Beispiel sowas wie eine extrem hohe Grunderwerbsteuer, die den schnellen Weiterverkauf von Grundstücken arg unattraktiv macht, wäre ein erster Schritt, dass ich sage...
Ja, oder sowas wie es es bei Aktien gibt, dass du die mindestens zehn Jahre halten musst, bevor sich Steuer herverkaufen kannst.
Genau, also das könnte man bei so Grunderwerbsteuern mit anbinden. Also dass man, ja, oder eine Abschöpfung von Weiterverkäufen, wenn ich sage, irgendwie innerhalb von zehn Jahren verkäufe, die, weiß nicht, das Doppelte oder das Dreifache des Ursprungspreises realisieren. Da kommt 75 Prozent Gewinnsteuer drauf, die ich für einen sozialen Wohnungsbau ausgebe. Also, naja. Na, das hört sich aus einer...
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde es eine Frechheit. Ich frage auch bei der Straßenverkehrsordnung, nicht die Autofahrer, ob sie damit einverstanden sind, dass hier eine 30-Zonen-Hin kommt. Das wird halt gemacht. Ich meine, hallo?
Ja?
Ich kriege immer Blutdruck hier.
Also, der Schutz des Eigentums spielt ja schon eine große Rolle in unserer Gesellschaft. Was mir aber einfällt bei diesem Besteuern und so, also, dass die FDP, du hast sie ja schon angesprochen, die ist ja sozusagen in allen... Als Gattungsbegriff. Ja, als Gattungsbegriff. Ist die ja in sozusagen allen sozialpolitischen Debatten immer dafür bekannt, dass man sagt, es soll hier keine leistungslosen Einkommen geben. Also, wenn es um Hartz IV geht oder um irgendwas, das darf immer nicht leistungslos sein. Und wir haben so einen Bereich, wo es leistungslose Ertragssteigerungen gibt. Also, weil der Preis des Grundstücks irgendwie verdoppelt in vier Jahren. Da ist ja nicht mal eine Aktivität dazu notwendig. Und so wie hier im Stadtbad euer Eigentümer lang genug gewartet hat, bis der Preis steigt, also das ist eigentlich, also auch für so die Freunde der kapitalistischen Wirtschaft, ist das eigentlich ein systemwidriges Element.
Es ist ja dann keine Leistung, die sich wieder lohnt, sondern nur...
Besitz muss sich wieder lohnen. Reichtum muss sich lohnen.
Reichtum muss sich wieder lohnen, genau. Die Frage zu den Regulierungsmöglichkeiten und den Genossenschaften, wie groß ist denn eigentlich der Anteil an so genossenschaftlichen und gewaltnützigen Wohnungsbau in Berlin? Also wie viel haben wir denn da so? Es ist doch, also so optisch sieht es noch relativ viel aus.
Naja, wir haben diese ungefähr 15 Prozent, also 300.000 Wohnungen, die den landeseigenen Wohnungsunternehmen gehören. Also für die, die in Berlin jetzt sich auskennen, sowas wie Hovoge, Gesobau, Gevoback und Degevo. Also so heißen die Stadt und Land. Jetzt habe ich auch fast alle genannt. Dazu haben wir zehn Prozent ungefähr des Wohnungsbestandes sind in den Händen von Genossenschaften, also 180.000 Wohnungen. Und dann gibt es noch eine Handvoll Wohnungen, die tatsächlich eher so mildtätigen Stiftungen oder sozusagen selbstverwalteten Konstrukten gehören, die aber von der Zahl her fast zu vernachlässigen sind. Und das Problem ist, dass es in Deutschland, das ist so im Schatten der Wiedervereinigung geschehen, 1989, dass das Prinzip der Gemeinnützigkeit im Wohnungssektor abgeschafft wurde. Damals hat ja vor allen Dingen CSU argumentiert, das ist eine unglaubliche Steuerverschwendung, also weil diese gemeinnützigen Wohnungsunternehmen von der Körperschaft Steuer und sonstigen Steuern befreit waren. Dafür aber angehalten war, eine preisgünstige Wohnung zur Verfügung zu stellen. Braucht man alles nicht mehr. Und dann hat man die abgeschafft und bis heute ist sie nicht wieder eingeführt worden. Und es gibt jetzt erst so in den letzten Jahren aber eine, sagen wir mal, gesellschaftlich relativ marginalisierte Diskussion von deutschen Mieterboden, Linke, Grüne im Bundestag, versucht, die Wiedereinführung der Gemeinnützigkeit im Wohnungssektor überhaupt zu diskutieren. Und das würde natürlich das Potenzial von möglichen Akteuren oder Bauherren deutlich steigern. Und Gemeinnützigkeit ist eigentlich ein tolles Prinzip, wenn ich sage, ja, und weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal einen Verein gegründet habt, der diesen gemeinnützigen Status hat.
Habt ganz versucht.
Ja, so und warum will man diesen Status haben? Weil man dann als Verein wenig Steuern zahlen muss. Und die Idee dahinter ist ja, wenn ich gemeinnützig bin oder der Zweck, den ich hier betreibe als Wohnungsunternehmen oder als Verein, wenn der gemeinnützig ist, dann brauche ich keine Steuern zahlen. Weil die Steuer würde ja nur dazu genommen werden, um irgendwelche gemeinnützigen Zwecke staatlicherseits zu erbringen.
Da spar ich mir andere Investitionen an den Staaten.
Das heißt also, ich entlaste hier jemanden dafür, dass er einen bestimmten Zweck erfüllt. Den ich sonst als Staat ja selber in die Hand nehmen müsste. Das ist eigentlich ein tolles Prinzip. Ich habe auch gerade mit Kollegen zusammen Modelle gerechnet, wie viel Steuern eigentlich in einem typischen Wohnungsbau steckt. Da kommt man dazu, dass man die Kosten im Vergleich zu einem Baukosten um mindestens ein Drittel senken kann. Wenn ich sage, alle Steuern, die hier drinstecken, davon bist du freigestellt oder kriegst du die erlassen. Das heißt also, statt 10 Euro würde man 7 Euro Kosten am Ende haben für so einen Bau. Wenn ich das kombiniere mit klassischen Fördermitteln oder mit einem zinsfreien Darlehen von irgendeiner Bundesagentur, dann braucht man auch keine Häuser mehr für 10 Euro, sondern dann kann man Neubauten zu 5,50 Euro oder 5 Euro eigentlich errichten und vermieten. Und es ist im Prinzip rausgerechnet die Steuern, die der Staat sonst nimmt und es ist rausgerechnet, das was Private an Gewinnerwartung haben. Und es ist rausgerechnet, die Zinsgewinne mit den Banken rechnen. Aber bei dieser Niedrigzinsphase, die wir gerade haben, ist es in anderen Bereichen auch bei erneuerbaren Energien, dass die KfW, also die Kreditanstalt für den Wiederaufbau, zinsfreie Darlehen gibt.
Moment, du sagst, für 5,50 Euro oder so was in der Größe, dann kann man bewohnbare Bauten errichten?
Genau, zum selben Standard, wie sonst für 10 oder 11 Euro gebaut werden.
Warte mal, da würde ich aber dann gerne gegenrechnen, wie viel andere Ausgaben sich der Staat dann sparen kann, weil nicht mehr irgendwie Hartz IV die Kosten tragen muss oder weil nicht mehr...
Genau, also...
Gibt es da irgendwelche Versuche des Austraillen?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil man natürlich in so einer Modellrechnung jetzt nicht die tatsächliche Belegung vorhersehen kann. Aber es ist relativ deutlich, dass es einen größeren Effekt hätte, als wenn ich versuche, von 10 Euro auf 5 Euro mit irgendwelchen Wohngeldzahlungen runterzureduzieren.
Nimm mal kurz deine Rechnung zu hinterfragen, weil das interessiert mich. Das heißt, das rechnest du dann auf 30 Jahre oder sowas?
Das Schöne bei den Gemeinnützigen ist ja, dass die dauerhaft gemeinnützig sind. Und das ist ja bei den jetzigen Förderprogrammen ist es ja ein totaler Wahnsinn, dass wir im Prinzip sehr hohe Förderquoten haben, dass den Förderanteil oder dem Fördervolumen angeht im sozialen Wohnungsbau. Aber in den Förderprogrammen eigentlich eine zeitlich befristete Sozialbindung drin ist ja. Sozialbindung drin ist Belegungs- und Mietpreisbindung. Das heißt, so wie Förderung in Deutschland bisher funktioniert, ist es eigentlich eine Wirtschaftsförderung mit einer sozialen Zwischennutzung. Also ich finanziere einen privaten Bauherren in dem Bau seiner Wohnung und sage ich übernehme für die ersten 20 oder 30 Jahre hier deine Refinanzierungsaufwendung durch die Zuschüsse, die ich dir gebe und die Darlehen, die ich dir ausreiche. Und wenn du dann sozusagen im Immobilienwirtschaftlich-Langfrist-Effekt auf den grünen Zweig kommst und alle deine Fremdkredite abgezahlt hast, dann sage ich, die Bindung fällt jetzt weg und du kannst es auf den freien Wohnungsmarkt vermieten. Und um aus diesem Wahnsinn herauszukommen, gibt es diese Diskussion um gemeinnützige Wohnbauträger, wo man sagt, was für ein Wahnsinn, hier kann ich jetzt fördern, aber einmal öffentlich gefördert ist dann dauerhaft sozial gebunden. Das wäre natürlich ein Vorteil für die Stadtentwicklung und so ein Förderprogramm könnte ich natürlich von Privaten nicht verlangen. Ich kann jetzt nicht zum Privaten gehen und sagen, ich finanziere dir hier mal die ersten 20 Jahre deiner Kapitalkosten und dafür musst du mir aber auf Dauer irgendeinen sozialen Effekt geben. Dann würde niemand das Programm nehmen. Wir hatten vorhin das Thema schon mal, dass die Rahmenbedingungen, die ich setze, tatsächlich einen Einfluss darauf haben, wer die Akteure sind. Wenn jetzt immer gesagt wird, naja, ohne private, wird es gar keinen Wohnungsbau in der Stadt geben, dann stimmt das unter den jetzigen Bedingungen fast nur private bauen. Ja, aber wenn ich die Bedingungen verändere, dann kann ich natürlich auch Bedingungen schaffen, wo man sagt, wow, das ist aber für selbst organisierte Baugruppen, das ist für Genossenschaften, das ist für gemeinnützige Wohnungsunternehmen echt ein attraktives Angebot und eine attraktive Rahmenbedingung.
Das heißt also, wenn man sagt, okay, man schafft halt Förderprogramme, die primär darauf ausgerichtet sind, dass sich Leute zusammentun und Genossenschaften, das war es auch immer, um Lücken zu bebauen und so, bleibt ja immer noch das Problem mit den Grundstückspreisen, die ja nun eher problematisch hoch sind, wo du dann halt irgendwie nicht mehr auf die 5,50 Euro kommen kannst, wenn du die Berliner aktuellen Grundstückspreise mit einrechnest, oder?
Naja, da muss man auch ran.
Ich hinterfrage jetzt nur das Modell so ein bisschen. Ich finde es sehr faszinierend, aber ich versuche gerade, die Lücken da drin zu finden.
Man muss die erstmal geordnet pleitegehen lassen, indem man ihnen den Nachtzug irgendwie abschneidet.
Wenn man jetzt anfängt, so einen gemeinnützigen Wohnungsbau zu etablieren, dann würde man sagen, du gehst jetzt gar nicht auf den privaten Markt, sondern du nutzt jetzt die städtischen Grundstücke, die wir noch haben. Und diese städtischen Grundstücke, die musst du auch gar nicht kaufen. Ich will die auch gar nicht verkaufen, sondern wir machen einen langfristigen Erbbaupachtvertrag mit dir. Und gerade für diese ersten 20 Jahre, in der du mit Refinanzierung von irgendwas zu tun hast, setzen wir auch den Erbaurechtszins relativ niedrig an. Und dann, wenn du später sozusagen deine Baukosten refinanziert hast, dann steigt der Erbauzins und wird mit der Miete verrechnet. So wäre ein relativ übliches und ungangbares Modell. Kann man erst mal machen. Und wenn man in der gleichen Zeit schafft, die spekulativen Ertragserwartungen in der Stadt zu senken, dann werden natürlich auch nicht mehr so spekulative Preise für die Grundstücke gezahlt. Das war ja vorhin der Mechanismus. Ich bin nur bereit, einen hohen Preis für ein Grundstück zu bezahlen, wenn ich damit rechnen kann, dass ich das auch wiederkriege, wenn ich nach und nach das sozusagen umstelle und sage, der Kauf des Grundstücks, der kostet dich auch richtig viel Steuern. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du es einfach mal ausprobieren kannst und zur Not an irgendjemanden weiterverkaufst, weil es wird gar niemanden geben, der es weiter kaufen möchte, weil dann schon wieder die Steuern anfallen.
Na gut, aber dann kann man auch wiederum argumentieren, dass wenn hohe Steuern drauf ist, hast du dann automatisch eine Preissteigerung mit jedem Verkauf, weil du... Genau.
Und der würde bei gleichzeitigem Ausbau des gemeinnützigen sozialen Wohnungssektors, aber dazu führen, dass sich irgendwann die Leute fragen, warum soll ich 12, 13 Euro bei einem Privaten bezahlen, wenn ich auch für 6 oder 7 Euro beim gemeinnützigen wohnen kann. Also das ist ja das Prinzip, was aus Wien relativ bekannt ist, wo es einen großen gemeinnützigen Sektor gibt. Ja, der dämpft die allgemeine Preisentwicklung. Oder, was dort sozusagen die Strategie ist, die privaten Wohnungsangebote versuchen, bestimmte Nischen zu besetzen, die es in dem Gemeindewohnungsbau nicht gibt. Also dann tatsächlich Luxuswohnungen.
Oder sehr große Wohnungen.
Oder so eine Form von Wohnungen, wo du sagen kannst, die kriegst du dort nicht und deshalb sind die Leute bereit, hier einen hohen Preis zu bezahlen. Aber sonst hat es natürlich klar, je größer der preiswerte Sektor, desto stärker ist der Effekt auf die Gesamtmarktentwicklung.
Wie vermeidest du denn, dass die FDP vor den EuGH zieht und sagt, das ist eine Marktverzerrung? Da würde ich mir noch Sorgen machen, dass sie sagen, wenn ihr hier als Staat mit irgendwelchen allgemeinen nützigen Firmen hier gegen unsere kommerziellen Mieter macht, dass das irgendwie auf der Schiene angreifbar ist.
Da würde ich erst mal sagen, gibt es ja Gemeinnützigkeit in anderen Ländern für den Wohnungsbereich. Österreich hat es gerade im Europarecht durchgeklagt. In Niederlanden gibt es das. Die haben das gerade durchgeklagt.
Die haben das durchgeklagt, okay.
Da muss man sagen, die hatten so ein bisschen Bestandschutz. Die hatten ja schon Gemeinnützigkeit. Wir würden die jetzt sozusagen neu einführen. Es gibt vielleicht dann nochmal höhere Hürden. Und das Grundargument ist aber, glaube ich, dass man sagt, unser gemeinnütziger Wohnungsbau mit diesen 5 Euro oder vielleicht sind es auch 6,50 Euro, der richtet sich an Gruppen, die von keinem dieser Marktakteure im Neubau überhaupt angesprochen wird. Also wir sind gar keine Konkurrenz für dich, weil wir können jetzt mal schauen, wie viele private Mietwohnungen unter 6,50 Euro wurden in den letzten vier Jahren in Berlin neu gebaut. Keine. Das heißt also, das ist gar nicht dein Klientel, du willst ja über 6,50 Euro vermieden. Das ist glaube ich die Hauptargumentation und umgesetzt wird es dann mit diesen sogenannten Wohnberechtigungsscheinen, dass man sagt, also die Wohnungen, die in so einem gemeinnützigen Wohnungsbau oder auch im sozialen Wohnungsbau errichtet werden, die werden gar nicht der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung gestellt, sondern die richten sich an diejenigen, die über so einen Wohnberechtigungsschein eine bestimmte Einkommensgrenze unterschreiten. Und das ist glaube ich das tragfähigste Argument für diese.
Ja, weil natürlich da halt natürlich immer, also ich meine, dieses Wohnberechtigungsscheinkonzept hat ja auch so relativ viele Kritikpunkte, weil natürlich dann halt immer gerade im Grenzbereich schon größere Zonen von Leuten entstehen.
Ich hätte mir doch mal gedacht, wie das funktioniert.
Na ist halt ganz einfach, wenn du halt irgendwie wenig Geld verdienst, weil du halt irgendwie nur Hartz-IV kriegst oder halt irgendwie Student bist oder halt irgendwie ein geringes Einkommen hast, kriegst du halt einen Wohnberechtigungsschein und der berechtigt dich zu, theoretisch muss man momentan sagen, dazu halt Wohnungen in diesem Sektor zu mieten.
Und die Miete zahlt deine Stadt oder nicht?
Nö, das geht darum, dass, weiß nicht, im sozialen Wohnungsbau.
Zu dieser Art Wohnung. Es gibt Wohnungen, die kannst du nur mit so einem Wohnberechtigungsschein mieten.
Ach so, aber wir haben praktisch keine davon.
Naja, wir haben bei den Wohnungsbaugesellschaften den landeseigenen. Die haben 300.000 Wohnungen und müssen jetzt, glaube ich, bei der Neuvermietung 60 Prozent an WBS-Inhaber vermieten. Also da gibt es jetzt eine Auflage. Im sozialen Wohnungsbau, also in den geförderten Wohnungen, da haben wir in Berlin noch 100.000 ungefähr, sollen jetzt neue dazukommen. Da muss jede Wohnung, wenn ich da neu einziehe, dann sagt er, das ist ja gefördert. Und geförderte Wohnungen kriegst du nur, wenn du so ein WBS hast, also so ein Wohnberechtigungsschein. Da wird es darum gehen, diesen Bestand auszuweiten.
Rufen die dann auch weniger Miete auf an jemanden mit so einem Wohnberechtigungsschein, als wenn sie das normal vermieten?
Na, bei den Wohnungsbaugesellschaften, die sind jetzt angehalten. Also sonst macht es keinen Sinn. Und im geförderten Wohnungsbau ist es bis auf Ausnahmen auch so, dass die Miete natürlich auch gedämpft ist. Also belegungs- und mietpreisgebunden gehört dann häufig zusammen. Sonst wär es ja absurd. Und das, was Frank irgendwie gesagt hat, also was ist mit denen, die sozusagen knapp über der Grenze liegen, das ist natürlich bei all diesen, sozusagen, weiß nicht, bei der Definition von berechtigten Gruppen immer ein Problem. Dann fehlt es jetzt knapp und du bist nicht dabei. Und das, was wir aber in Berlin zur Zeit oder in den letzten Jahren gemacht haben, ist, dass zum Beispiel diese Einkommensgrenzen für die Berechtigung, für so einen Bundberechtigungsschein sozusagen immer weiter hochgezoomt wurde.
Also die wurden angepasst.
Die wurden angepasst.
Ich kann mich erinnern, so damals, als ich noch irgendwie so unterwegs war in solchen Vierteln, war das halt so ein häufiges Problem, was Leute hatten, so dann, hm, soll ich den Job jetzt annehmen? Weil dann kann ich nicht mehr in der Wohnung und so. Dann also diese, diese Schwierigkeiten.
Also da gibt es zwei. Also das eine wird so ein bisschen so angepasst. Und in Berlin sind, glaube ich, zurzeit 54, 55 Prozent aller Haushalte haben den Einkommen, dass die berechtigten Wohnberechtigung scheinen zu nehmen. Also da kann ich sagen, so das ist jetzt nicht eine kleine Gruppe. Also da kann man sagen, bei den anderen 45 Prozent gibt es auch noch welche. Die könnten auch Unterstützung gebrauchen, aber irgendwo ist eine Grenze. Und das andere, was bei diesen ganzen Regeln, was, glaube ich, früher tatsächlich im sozialen Wohnungsbau ein Problem war, dass man gesagt hatte, du musst dann auch noch, wenn du schon in der Wohnung wohnst, auch nach fünf oder sechs Jahren deinen Wohnberechtigungsschein vorzeigen, sonst kriegst du eine Fehlbelegungsabgabe und musst eine riesige Miete bezahlen. Und das ist natürlich ein System, was, sagen wir mal, sehr segregationsfördernd wirken kann, weil dann die Besserverdienenden aus den Häusern ausziehen. Kann man sagen, ist ja auch ganz gut, weil es ja eine Sozialwohnung ist, soll wieder jemand anders mit dem Wohnberechtigungsschein einziehen. Aber man kann sich natürlich auch vorstellen, dass man sagt, man nimmt ein festes Zugangskriterium und sagt, also wer rein will, der muss sozusagen den Wohnberechtigungsschein nachweisen. Aber ich muss sozusagen dann, wenn ich drin wohne, sozusagen nicht mehr ausziehen, weil ich den dann nicht mehr habe. Ja, das wäre ja dann eine absolute Vorstellung.
Das führt auch in anderen Städten zu diesen vererbten Mietverträgen, also die dann halt so unter Mieter in fünfter Generation, die dann halt in so einer, also ja klar, Probleme gibt es dann immer so.
Probleme gibt es ja immer.
Die Frage, die ich noch so habe, ist so, was Berlin, da ist ja nun so ein bisschen angetreten, um das mal vielleicht zu versuchen, jetzt ein bisschen besser zu machen im Rahmen seiner geringen finanziellen Möglichkeiten. Siehst du denn da eine Chance, also dass es halt irgendwie eine effektive Möglichkeit gibt, hier mal so ein Beispiel zu setzen, wie man es anders machen könnte?
Naja, die Voraussetzungen sind ja relativ günstig. Also so von der politischen Mehrheitskonstellation, die es gerade gibt. Es gibt also eine rot-rot-grüne Regierung in Berlin. Es gibt was, eine zweite, glaube ich, wichtige Voraussetzung, ist eine relativ starke Stadt- und mietenpolitische Protestszene in Berlin, die in den letzten Jahren auch nicht nur Demonstrationen gegen Mietsteigungen organisiert hat, sondern eine ganze Reihe von sehr, sagen wir mal, reformpolitischen Forderungen aufgestellt hat. Also hat vorhin schon mal Leute gesagt, die macht so einen Kataster mit den öffentlichen Liegenschaften. Es gibt konkrete Vorschläge, wie man den sozialen Wohnungsbau reformieren kann. Es gibt inzwischen durchgesetzt ein neues Gesetz, was die Mietermitbestimmung bei den landeseigenen Wohnungsbaugesellschaften stärkt. Da gibt es jetzt Mieterräte, die bis hin zu sitzen in den Aufsichtsräten Stimme bekommen werden. Also eine Reihe von so, ja, tatsächlich Reformen, die es vorher nicht gab, gibt es Möglichkeiten. Eine zweite relativ gute Voraussetzung ist, dass nach über 15 Jahren Austeritätspolitik, also wo der Sparzwang über allem stand, die neue Regierung ja das Jahrzehnt der Investitionen ausgerufen hat. Also da hat der Finanzsenator Kolatz-Arndt eine ganze Reihe von neuen Instrumenten geschaffen. Also irgendwie so einen riesigen Fond zur Finanzierung der wachsenden Stadt, aus dem verschiedene Projekte finanziert werden sollen, die auch den Wohnungsbau umfassen. Man hat jetzt zur Stärkung der landeseigenen Wohnungsunternehmen, die sollen ja von diesen 300.000 auf 400.000 Wohnungen ihren Bestand ausweiten. Da hat man relativ interessantes Modell gefunden, dass man nicht gesagt hat, wir geben euch Geld, damit ihr Wohnung kauft, sondern man hat gesagt, weil die Zinsen ja international an den Finanzmärkten zu günstig sind, wir statten euch mit mehr Eigenkapital aus und ihr kümmert euch dann darum, liquide zu sein, um neu zu bauen und die Bestände anderweitig auszuweiten.
Geht das nicht schief, wenn dann die Zinsen wieder steigen? Also da wird das ja durchaus zu rechnen. Ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesen, jetzt sind gerade die Zinsen günstig, lass es uns mal außen zum Modellen.
Das nicht auszunutzen wäre, glaube ich, auch kein Weg. Ich glaube, dass der kaufmännische Verstand inzwischen im Überfluss, würde ich fast sagen, da ist. Also man hat ja die Wohnungsunternehmen in den letzten zehn Jahren im Prinzip auf modernste Unternehmenskulturen, was die Bewirtschaftung angeht, sozusagen getrimmt, was manchmal zu so Widersprüchen führt, dass die nicht so richtig verstehen, wenn man sagt, ihr habt jetzt vor allen Dingen soziale Aufgaben. Also das mit der schwarzen Null ist total wichtig. Aber ihr sollt jetzt auch hier die armen Schlucker in der Stadt mit Wohnung versorgen. Also aber das lernen die inzwischen. Und von daher glaube ich, dass die dann schon in der Lage sind, Kredite diese aufnehmen, gut abzusichern. Aber das war ja nur ein Beispiel dafür, dass das Land Berlin im Moment Überschüsse generiert und auch willig ist, die in Investitionen umzusetzen. Das ist für ganz viele von den wohnungspolitischen Maßnahmen, auch in anderen Infrastrukturbereichen, eine wichtige Voraussetzung. Also dass man mit diesem, wir kreplen uns am Sparzwang entlang, dass das ein Ende hat. Und das ist eine wichtige Voraussetzung dafür, dass tatsächlich Dinge auch verändert werden. Und wir haben jetzt ja schon die ersten Monate des neuen Regierens. Also gab es da zum Beispiel in Kreuzberg zwei Fälle, in denen ein Vorkaufsrecht gezogen wurde. Das heißt, dass dort...
Die Stadt ein Vorkaufsrecht hatte.
Wo die Kommune das genommen hat und die über Stadt- oder Wohnungsbaugesellschaften dann abgesichert wurde. Ja, und das ist natürlich ein, gerade in den Aufwertungsgebieten, großer Pluspunkt, wenn sich Eigentümer da nicht an die Auflagen im Milieuschutz halten, die es gibt, dann zu sagen, zur Not entschädigen wir dich jetzt einfach und steigen hier ein. Oder in dem einen Fall war es ja in der Wrangelstraße so ein tatsächlich grenzwertiges Beispiel, wo der Ursprungseigentümer alle Wohnungen aufgeteilt hatte in Eigentumswohnungen. Sozusagen die Aufteilung fand noch statt, bevor diese Umwandlungsverordnung kam. Und dann alle Wohnungen einzeln als Einzeleigentum an einen luxemburgischen Fond verkauft hat. Also sozusagen im Grundbuch waren es sozusagen Dutzende Einzelverkäufe. Bei Einzelverkäufen von Eigentumswohnungen hat der Staat in der Regel kein Vorkaufsrecht, sondern nur der Mieter, aber die konnten und wollten auch nicht. Und da hat der Bezirk Kreuzberg-Friedrichshain aber richtigerweise gesagt, na wenn ihr alle Wohnungen in dem Haus gleichzeitig als Einzelwohnungen um, dann ist es ja so, als würdet ihr das ganze Haus auf einmal verkaufen und fürs ganze Haus können wir ein Vorkaufsrecht sozusagen ziehen.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die dann irgendwie durch die Instanzen geklagt werden muss, oder?
Der hat verzichtet zu klagen inzwischen. Soweit ich weiß. Aber das zeigt so ein bisschen die Trendwende, dass der politische Wille da ist, einen Spielraum eher für die Intervention auszulesen und auszunutzen und nicht zu sagen, hier sind wir gar nicht zuständig. Drei, vier Jahre vorher hätte dasselbe Amt gesagt, das sind ja lauter Einzelverkäufe hier, Paragraph XY, sind wir gar nicht zuständig.
Würdest du denn unterm Strich sagen, das läuft oder eher so, ach du Scheiße, da muss jetzt mal jemand. Das klingt jetzt deutlich, ich will nicht sagen optimistischer, aber doch.
Also doch optimistischer als erwartet haben wir.
Ich hab mit einer Bauruine gerechnet, und jetzt sehe ich hier so zarte Pflänzchen der Hoffnung.
Ja, aber die sind wirklich zart und das... Ich will jetzt hier auch nicht als Berufsoptimist irgendwie durch eure Sendung laufen, aber die Voraussetzung dafür, dass sich diese zarten Pflänzchen da verstetigen, das wird tatsächlich davon abhängig sein, inwieweit es einen öffentlichen Druck auch weiter auf die Regierung gibt. Und das ist ja das, also, weiß nicht, glaube ich, das Schöne, wenn du so eine linken, progressiven Regierungskoalition hast, dass die sich das eigentlich nicht leisten dürfen, ausgerechnet den sozialen Fragen auszuweichen. Weißt du, also wenn ich irgendwie konservativ-liberale Regierungskoalition hab und sage, hier dürfte aber die armen Sozialmieter nicht vergessen, dann sagen die, ne, wir haben aber jetzt hier an die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Stadt gedacht und sind sozusagen mit sich im Rhein. Und wenn ich aber eine Koalition hab, wo Sozialdemokraten, Linke und Grüne sind und sage, ihr habt versprochen, also die Linke hat ja sogar versprochen, euch gehört die Stadt, wir können jetzt sagen, wir sind euch, wir sind jetzt da und wollen das Stückchen hier abbekommen, dann glaube ich, dass das tatsächlich eine Konstellation ist, wo man Forderungen durchsetzen kann. Ob das jetzt in allen Fällen aufgeht, würde ich jetzt hier nicht versprechen, aber...
Es gibt einige positive Beispiele, die das schon mehr als ich gerechnet habe.
Dort, deutlich mehr als ich gedacht habe. Ich hab noch so zwei Fragen. Die eine ist, wir haben jetzt ja gerade durchaus einen nicht so ganz kleinen Anteil an so Start-up-Economie in Berlin. Also so, naja, jetzt nicht unbedingt Google und Zalando, aber die sind ja auch, was jetzt dieses Vorantreiben der Gentrifizierung in Kreuzberg angeht, ja doch relativ weit vorne mit dabei so. Das ist ja eigentlich so eine klassische Arbeit, die findet wieder in der Stadt statt, aber halt in einem Einkommensdifferenzial, was halt irgendwie eigentlich, ja, wenn man so in Silicon Valley guckt, oder in San Francisco guckt, halt so auf Dauer halt jetzt auch nicht so besonders gesund ist für so eine Gegend. Wie geht man als Stadt sinnvoll mit so was um?
Na im Moment werden die ja sehr hofiert, also weil sie so ein bisschen...
Geld in die Stadt, also ich meine, das ist halt so...
Für die neue Ökonomie da sind. Und ich glaube, dass die ersten Friktionen schon auch deutlich werden. In San Francisco hat man sich ja so ein bisschen, weiß nicht, also den Gentrification Faktor da des Google-Busses beschrieben, der seine Mitarbeiter in die Viertel fährt, wo dann sozusagen auch mit dem guten Geld, was die bekommen, die Aufwertung finanziert werden konnte. Und ich habe hier ein Beispiel gehört, dass Zelando im letzten Jahr, glaube ich, sich ein weitgehend entmietetes Haus in Friedrichshain gekauft hat, um vor allen Dingen internationalen Programmierer, die bei denen auch zeitweise nur für ein, zwei Jahre anheuern, mit Wohnungen zu versorgen, weil die erst mal selber Opfer der Aufwertungsdynamik in Berlin waren, weil die festgestellt haben, ich kann hier meinen russischen oder spanischen Programmierer zwar in die Stadt holen, aber der findet anders als noch vor fünf Jahren auch mit diesem guten Gehalt, was ich ihm hier zahle, nicht unmittelbar die Wohnung, die er haben will. Nicht nur, weil er es nicht bezahlen kann, sondern eher aus dieser riesigen Konkurrenzsituation, die immer beschrieben wird, da ist eine Wohnungsbegehung, 30 Leute stehen da und dann kannst du die Sprache nicht, also bist du eigentlich immer benachteiligt. Um diese Lücke zu schließen, haben die im Prinzip von einem anderen entmietetes Haus in Friedrichshain gekauft, wo dann, ich sag mal so die Zilando-WGs quasi sozusagen dann untergebracht werden. Und das deutet ja schon so ein bisschen in die Richtung, dass zumindest die Erfolgreichen von den Start-ups wahrscheinlich ihre eigenen Wege finden werden, sich in der Konkurrenz um Wohnungen in der Innenstadt auch relativ deutlich durchzusetzen. Bei dem Modell bin ich mir nicht mal ganz sicher, ob so, dass das jetzt ein entmietetes Haus war. Das ist natürlich irgendwie total beknackt, weil da musste Verdrängung gesetzt werden. Aber um den Bogen zu schließen, im Prinzip ist das eine moderne Variante von dem Siemens-Haus.
Von Werkswohnungen.
Ja, von Werkswohnungen. Und wenn man die jetzt dazu bringen könnte, dass man sagt, dann baut die doch auch gleich neu, dass sozusagen kein Verdrängungspotenzial da ist, dann könnte das einen Effekt haben. Und das, was wir aber auch beobachten, ist ja das, was im letzten Jahr bekannt geworden ist, dass diese Samba-Brüder, dass die aus ihrem Firmen-Geflecht zunehmend in Immobilien, in Gewerbeimmobilien, aber auch in Wohnungsimmobilien investieren. Also das heißt also, dass bisher so eine Vorstellung war, in Berlin sind diese Start-ups und die Locken-Anlage suchen das Kapital an, um dann im besten Fall Arbeitsplätze und irgendetwas zu kreieren. Und dass es jetzt offensichtlich aber auch schon so einen Überschuss gibt, dass dort, wo wirklich Geld verdient wird, dass sozusagen im Immobilienbereich finanziert wird.
Und dort Kritiker würden sagen, dass die Samba-Brüder kein Geld mit den Start-ups verdienen, deswegen die Immobilien investieren. Aber gut.
Na und andererseits würde ich auch sagen, wenn die hier schon eigene Gebäude kaufen müssen, um für ihre Leute Wohnungen zu bauen, dann würde ich sagen, das ist ein Standortnachteil von Berlin, der jetzt so krass ist, dass die Industrie aktiv werden muss. Also das würde ich nicht so positiv sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Und da kommen wir auch wieder full circle zurück. Wir können zwar sagen, wäre doch schön, wenn ihr bauen würdet, aber wenn wir die Grundstücke schon alle verscheuert haben, die wir ihnen geben könnten, um darauf zu bauen, ist ja auch doof. Und das hat Berlin halt gemacht die letzten Jahre.
Die Frage ist ja, wie geht man mit so einem Problem um, dass es halt so Firmen gibt, die, weil sie in der globalen Wertschöpfungseconomie halt relativ weit oben auf der Leiter stehen, halt auch relativ hohe Gehälter zahlen können. Und was aber, wenn man jetzt so mal wieder mal so San Francisco Silicon Valley als Extrembeispiel nimmt, dann eben auch irgendwann nicht mehr reicht. Also da ist es ja so, dass diese gesamte Wirtschaft im Silicon Valley funktioniert ja nur noch deswegen überhaupt, weil es Firmen gibt, so Autowerkstätten und Restaurants und so, denen ihr Grund und Boden schon seit diversen zehn Jahren gehört und die deswegen halt ihre Preise nicht aus einer Refinanzierung dieser Immobilie kalkulieren müssen. Was aber wiederum bedeutet, gibt es Leute, die verdienen 150.000 Dollar im Jahr und können sich dafür nicht irgendeine Art von Wohnung leisten, die irgendwie adäquat wäre, ohne dass sie eineinhalb Stunden Commuting-Time haben, also eineinhalb Stunden Panel-Zeit haben. Und weil die Aufwertung halt schon so krass ist innerhalb von San Francisco, ist so die ganzen größeren Start-ups da, die haben sich alle Häuser gekauft mit Wohnungen drin, also schon sehr lange, weil sie halt Leuten, die sie anheuern, nicht sagen können, naja, viel Glück bei der Wohnungssuche. Das ist halt schon so ein Ultra-Verdichtungseffekt, der dann jetzt auch schon dazu führt, dass die normale Wirtschaft einfach überhaupt nicht mehr funktionieren kann, weil es außer an Start-up-Unternehmen Vermieten nichts mehr gibt, was irgendwie die Immobilienkosten refinanziert.
Wobei, das ist auch eine Perspektivfrage. Da hab ich einen Artikel drüber gelesen, der mich immer noch beschäftigt, das ist jetzt schon zwei Jahre her. Das war so eine linke Zeitung, die meinte, das ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Tech-Branche als erste einen ausreichend hohen Prozentsatz von ihren Profiten an ihre Leute auszahlt, weil es die erste gerechte Branche ist. Alle anderen machen es so, dass sie nun Hungerlohn auszahlen und dann sind halt die Preise niedrig. Das sei aber ein gutes Zeichen, dass die jetzt alle genug Kohle haben, um sozusagen die Gegend in den Boden zu nageln. Also es ist nicht so einfach, wie man das jetzt sehen will.
Na gut, aber letzten Endes ist es ja so ein...
Ich meine, die Kohle perkuliert ja durch die Wirtschaft ruhig. Da verdient ja irgend einer dran.
Na gut, trickle down ist ja nun nicht...
Nein, also wenn du so viel Kohle für Lebenserhaltung ausgeben musst, dann geht es ja in die Wirtschaft um dich rum.
Nee, es geht in die Besitzer der Immobilien. Der Immobilienanteil an allem, was da passiert, also auch über die Mieten. Also die Mieten treiben ja alle anderen Preise.
Ja.
Beziehungsweise die Refinanzierungskosten der Grundstücke.
Und das ist vielleicht jetzt bei den gut bezahlten Start-up-Programmierern, Programmiererinnen nicht so das Problem, aber für alle anderen, gilt ja das, was ich sozusagen an Miete schon ausgegeben habe, das gebe ich sozusagen nicht mehr in anderen Kreisläufen aus. Also Miete macht dich ja nicht nur selber arm, sondern hat ja auch einen negativen Effekt auf die Bindennachfrage in allen anderen Bereichen. Und das ist, glaube ich, eher, wenn wir über Gefahr von Immobilienblasen und Effekten von immer steigenden Immobilienpreisen sprechen, was so eine volkswirtschaftliche Betrachtung, die relativ selten dargelegt wird. Also wenn Gefahr von Blase wird eigentlich immer nur auf die Immobilieninvestition selbst geschaut. Und ich habe letztens auch mal einen Ökonom kennengelernt, der mir erzählt hat, wie so ein Blasenindex funktioniert. Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass die sozusagen gar nicht die Leistungsfähigkeit der Einkommen in einem Gebiet auf Wohnungsmärkten in Deutschland mit einbeziehen, sondern dass die nur nach der Relation zwischen den Kaufpreisen für die Grundstücke und den Mietpreisen und Kaufpreisen für Eingriffswohnungen und den Mietpreisen schauen, die neu vermietet werden. Und solange sozusagen beides steigt, dann würde ich sagen, die Blase ist ja längst erreicht, weil nur noch ein Minderheit der Berliner Bevölkerung sich diese Wohnung leisten kann. Das ist für die aber nicht das Kriterium. Solange beides steigt, Miete und Preis für die Eigentumswohnung, dann ist es sozusagen die Blasengefahr gekappt. Und erst wenn sich sozusagen der Preis für die einzelne Wohnung von den Mietpreisen entkoppelt, dann sagen die, jetzt ist die Preissteigerung zu krass, weil die teure Eigentumswohnung kannst du gar nicht mehr mit den zurzeit hohen Mietpreisen refinanzieren.
Aber ist doch in Berlin eigentlich schon der Fall, oder nicht?
Jetzt kommt gerade, genau. Deshalb waren ja jetzt noch die ersten Artikel, die sagen, hier, hier muss... Ja, weiß nicht, also da kommt immer gleich ein Artikel hinterher, der sagt, die Blase, das ist gar keine Blase, das ist jetzt nur eine Unwucht und keiner, keiner soll sich Sorgen machen.
Und rechts daneben, rechts daneben die Fullpage-Anzeige für das neue Projekt, kaufen sie jetzt. Aber nee, aber tatsächlich die Frage, die sich mir halt schon stellt, ist, wenn ich mir jetzt so die Preise angucke, die gezahlt werden für Eigentumswohnungen, also jetzt mal da drüben nehmen, halt irgendwie 6500 Euro pro Quadratmeter. Das ist doch mit Miete in keiner Weise mehr reinzubekommen. Also das geht doch eigentlich rechnen.
Die zeigen dir ja, dass das mit den 22 Euro pro Quadratmeter Miete im Mikroappartement...
Na, das wollen wir mal sehen, ob das läuft.
Genau, aber das ist ja noch 45 Jahre gerechnet, oder wie? Also ich meine, das ist ja okay.
Ja, Geld kann ganz günstig Kredite aufnehmen, hab ich gehört.
Ja, na gut, aber ich meine jetzt so, aber trotzdem noch mal ganz erstaunlich diese Frage. Also eigentlich, also gefühlt, wenn ich mir so angucke, was ich an Miete zahle und was die Preise, die den Nachbarhäusern verlangt werden, das ist einfach nicht mal in der selben Tabellenkalkulation. Ja, also das funktioniert einfach irgendwie überhaupt nicht. Und trotzdem sehe ich halt irgendwie, dass die Preise, also die gezahlten Kaufpreise einfach immer noch weiter steigen.
Ja, Angebot und Nachfrage mein Freund.
Nee, aber die Frage, wenn es jetzt so eine Kalkulation einer Blase ist und die sich halt nur daran festmacht, erhältst du das denn für eine sinnvolle Kalkulation oder ist das eigentlich Quatsch?
Nee, ich finde es total Quatsch, weil es ja die volkswirtschaftlichen Konsequenzen und auch die soziale Basis für eine Refinanzierung von Immobilien völlig außer Acht lässt. Also ich kann mir natürlich sozusagen eine Ökonomie schon vorstellen, wo ich sozusagen immer auf den nächsten Dummen hoffe, der in der Lage ist, einen noch höheren Preis zu bezahlen. So funktioniert der Kunstmarkt auch. Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendeinen Picasso kaufe, also kann sein, dass ich den wirklich mag.
Du Banause, du.
Und mir jetzt ins Zimmer hänge. Aber ich kann mir auch sicher sein, es wird irgendwann jemanden geben, der zahlt noch mehr und der zahlt noch mehr und der zahlt noch mehr. Und so kann ich natürlich auch in ein Immobiliengeschäft denken. Man muss dann sozusagen nur hoffen, dass ich nicht der Letzte in dieser Verkaufskette bin, weil der Letzte hat ja gar keine Chance mehr, das zu zahlen, wiederzubekommen. Das Problem ist aber, dass in diesen Phasen der spekulativen Preistreiberei die daraus abgeleiteten Mieterwartungen auch steigen. Weil jeder sagt, ich muss jetzt wiederholen. Und das entkoppelt sich halt völlig von dem, was Leute in der Stadt wie Berlin zahlen können. Das wissen wir ja auch. Also der Anteil von Bevölkerungen, die 22 Euro pro Quadratmeter Miete zahlen können, ist relativ begrenzt. Klammer auf. Und die meisten von denen sind auch ökonomisch in der Lage, sich sowieso eine Eigentumswohnung zu leisten. Das heißt, da wird irgendwann an dem tatsächlichen Bedarf und auch an der tatsächlichen Zahlbarkeit vorbeigeplant.
Das heißt also, der effektivste Weg, eine Immobilienblase vorzubeugen, wäre eine durchgesetzte Mietpreisdecklung.
Ja, und der effektivste Weg, weil die Mietpreisbremse, da haben wir ja vorhin gesehen, macht das nicht so richtig. Und der momenteffektivste Weg ist ja das, was der Berliner und die Berlinerinnen sich sozusagen selbst ausgedacht haben, indem sie quasi in einen kollektiven Umzugsstreik gezogen sind. Also die Zahlen dieser Bindenumzüge sind um fast die Hälfte in den letzten Jahren zurückgegangen. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen keine wirklich bewusste Kollektive und sonstige Entscheidung.
Aber ökonomisch rational.
Aber das ist die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes. Naja, aber das ist ja sozusagen der…
Naja, ist ja doch. Die FDP hat recht. Ich möchte noch eine Sache ansprechen, die mir aufgefallen ist bei dieser Volkswirtschaft und die Betrachtung, dass ja die meisten Start-ups, die in Berlin gegründet werden, so Dienstleistungsdinger sind. Und das sind gerade die Sachen, für die man nach der Miete noch ein Restgehalt braucht, um das überhaupt marktfähig zu machen. Und das heißt, wir haben also einen doppelten negativen Effekt. Wir haben erstens die Miete macht die Leute arm. Zweitens volkswirtschaftlich scheiße. Und drittens aber auch, dass genau die Start-ups, die uns retten sollen, den graben wir hier die Kundschaft weg. Also man könnte eigentlich auf drei Ebenen schon dagegen argumentieren, dass wir jetzt hier die Mieten nicht deckeln.
Gut, da könnte man jetzt mit diesen globalen Verwertungszyklen, also das Produkt, was ein Start-up in Berlin entwickelt, jetzt nicht unbedingt in Berlin konsumiert werden muss.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ja, aber das, also jetzt von der Unternehmensrationalität her.
Dann haben wir wieder so eine Exportwirtschaft, die schon in Deutschland so gut funktioniert.
Funktioniert super. Was ich eher denke, weil ja diese Start-up-Ökonomie häufig so ein bisschen romantisiert wird als die kleinen Kollektive, die da irgendwas gemeinsam anfangen und so. Und dann sehen wir schon, das wird zu so einem riesigen Investitionsfeld selbst. Und das, was, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt hier, Hart und Negri, also so Philosophen, die sich sozusagen eigentlich mit der Postmoderne viel beschäftigt haben oder mit den Veränderungen in den letzten 20 Jahren, die haben ja irgendwann das auf den Punkt gemacht, haben gesagt, so die Stadt ist unsere Fabrik. Und haben gesagt, also das Industriezeitalter ist vorbei. Das, was an Kreativität, Produktivität und an Wertschöpfung heute noch stattfindet, ist eben nicht mehr die Industrie, sondern ist die Stadt selbst. Und Start-ups sind für mich eigentlich ein Musterbeispiel dafür, wie das funktioniert. Also, dass die in der Regel so ein städtisches Umfeld auch brauchen. Also, sonst würden irgendwie, weiß nicht, die Talente, die da anheuern, auch nicht kommen. Also, ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, ich mache jetzt Start-ups in Oranienburg oder in Brandenburg an der Havel. Also, da wäre ja genug Raum. Also, da ist irgendwie die Fabrik alle, aber...
Nee, das ist die Frage von Urban Density. Also, du bist halt einfach, also du, gut, ich kenne dich nun relativ gut und sehr genau. Und da ist es halt so, dass der Standout-Faktor für wo ist deine Firma entscheidet und wir haben darüber, was für Leute du kriegst.
Genau. Und das heißt, also, da ist ein städtischer Faktor drin.
Ja, ein großer.
Und man könnte das jetzt auch nochmal auch darauf beziehen, nur weil so eine Firmen in einem städtischen Umfeld agieren, wo auch andere sind, wo ich diese ständigen Konfrontations- und Kollaborationsmöglichkeiten habe und Kreativität überhaupt erst umtragen und all diese Urbanitätsversprechen. Die machen das sozusagen zur Produktions- und produktiven Ressource. Und für, ich sag mal jetzt, das globale Kapital, ist es ja relativ schwierig, an sozusagen diese Potenziale der Kreativität und Kollaboration heranzukommen. Weil anders als in der Industrie, gibt es sozusagen nicht den großen Manager, den Industriekapitän, der dir sozusagen den Takt der Kapitalproduktion vorschreibt und seinen Profit schon eingerechnet hat. Eigentlich ist es für das Kapital ein totales Problem, dass sozusagen aus so einer Kollaboration von Einzelnen plötzlich Werte geschaffen werden und die sind hochproduktiv, auch aus deren Vorstellungen. Und die muss jetzt irgendwie da rankommen.
Das ist aber gut contained. Also die Startup-Economie ist sehr, sehr gut darin, das hinzukriegen.
Genau, das ist der eine Weg. Und der zweite Weg ist aber, das ist das, was wir ja in Städten wie Berlin jetzt auch lernen, dass es noch einen zweiten Weg gibt, zumindestens die Werte abzuschöpfen. Indem ich sage, wenn ihr hier auf das städtische Umfeld angewiesen seid, dann hat das jetzt seinen Preis. Und das ist im Prinzip, wenn wir vorhin gesagt haben, so dieses leistungslose Abschöpfen von Immobiliengewinn. Das steht schon in einem Zusammenhang auch damit, dass man nach mein Grund und Boden wird für euch zur Wertschöpfung Ressource.
Also so eine Modelle gibt es ja schon. Also das gibt es auch Unternehmen als Städte, die es machen, dass sie sagen, okay, wir haben hier Gewerbeimmobilien, die sind in der Stadt, die sind jetzt vielleicht nicht so superschick, aber die sind halt für einen Start-up ideal. Und dann gibt es halt entweder für Anteile Mietfreiheit oder das sind dann sogenannte Incubators, das heißt, da können Firmen in ihre Anfangszeit hingehen und kriegen halt entweder einen stark reduzierten oder gar keine Miete und geben halt Anteile dafür ab. Die Verwertungsketten sind schon etabliert, das geht schon relativ klar, weil natürlich klar, wenn du halt irgendwie als Firma anfängst, ab einem bestimmten Punkt ist Miete halt ein nicht unsignifikanter Anteil von deinen Ausgaben. Und da musst du halt irgendwie mit umgehen. Und du kannst den Punkt, wo du halt dir tatsächlich dann mal richtige Büros mietest, zwar ein Stück weit hinaus schieben, aber halt auch nicht ewig. Aber das Interessante daran ist wiederum auch, dass die Gewerbeimmobilienpreise außerhalb des Ultra-Premium-Sektors ja nicht wirklich so dramatisch steigen wie die normalen Mietimmobilienpreise. Also zumindest, soweit ich es so mitbekomme, wenn so Freunde von mir sich in eine neue Firma gründen und was anmieten. So die Preise sind jetzt nicht so verschieden von vor zehn Jahren. So es ist jetzt nicht so, also nicht derselbe von irgendwie 7, 8 Euro auf 22 Euro. Das sieht man da eigentlich jetzt nur so in der Ultra-Innen-1A-Lage, aber jetzt nicht so in, so ein Gewerbelauf den Kreuzberg Christi war noch für einen 10A. Also das ist halt durchaus interessant, dass offensichtlich da halt eben die Begrenzung der möglichen Abschöpfung über die Miete erreicht ist, wenn es nicht mehr stark steigt. Also dass da offensichtlich der, klar in nachgefragten Lagen, gut ist natürlich immer noch teurer, aber da so eine Firma ja anders kräkulieren muss als ein Mieter, so eine Firma kann ja eigentlich, die kann, wenn sie rational handelt, nur bedingt beschließen, mehr Miete zu zahlen, um attraktiver zu sein. An irgendeinem Punkt muss ich das ja auch wieder rechnen. Du kannst ja irgendwie bestimmte Formen von Einzelhandel zum Beispiel nicht machen oberhalb eines bestimmten Preisniveaus. Was sich dann schon niederschlägt darin, dass da nur noch Tarketten sind und so. Aber selbst die haben ja dann irgendwann ein Problem, dass ihre Rendite pro Quadratmeter nicht mehr kompatibel mit der Miete ist, die da verlangt wird.
Ja, wir haben ja im Prinzip so eine umgekehrte Zweckentfremdung, also dass nach und nach irgendwie bisherige Gewerberäume in reale Wohnräume zurückverwandelt werden. Und ich wies irgendwie, mir eine große Tochter, die hatte eine von ihren WGs, die sie da in Friedrichshain hatte, die waren glaube ich in einem ehemaligen China-Restaurant, sozusagen unten reingebaut. Und ich wies, dass wir unter Umwandlung früher immer sozusagen andersrum polemisiert haben, gesagt haben, hier, die Wohnung muss erhalten bleiben, hier soll jetzt keine Zahnarztpraxis oder irgendein Anwaltsbüro irgendwie reingebaut werden, sondern die Wohnung muss erhalten sein.
Und inzwischen gibt es sozusagen diverse Anwälte, die in ihren Praxen wohnen. Also in ihren, ja, so also das so.
Also kannst du mit Wohnungsmieten mehr verdienen als mit Gewerbemieten.
Ja, schon schon spannend.
Aber weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das tatsächlich. Müssen wir ein bisschen im Auge behalten. Das ist so eine Reaktion auf diese vielleicht auch fürs Geschäftsmodell schlecht kalkulierbaren Mietentwicklung, sowohl für Gewerbemieten als auch für die Wohnungsmieten der Leute, die bei dir arbeiten. So eine Verschränkung von Start-up, Ökonomie und Immobilienmarkt vielleicht auch nochmal stärker kommt. Und das ist ja auch nicht mehr ganz so urwüchsig und gibt doch eine Reihe von so sozusagen auch größeren Projekten, wo große Gewärmeanlagen als Teil dieser eigentlich als so spontanen Ökonomie beschrieben.
Ich meine, so etwas wie Zalando, das ist halt keine spontane Ökonomie, das ist halt irgendwie Kapitalgesellschaftsverwertungsoptimierung. Aber ich will noch mal kurz einen Weg zurück zu Wohnungen machen. Das klassische Gegenargument gegen so eine Regulierung des Wohnungsmarktes ist zu sagen, eigentlich sollte sich die Stadt doch lieber darauf konzentrieren, dass mehr Leute Eigentümer ihrer Wohnung sind. Also das ist sozusagen der klassische neoliberale Argument zu sagen. So eigentlich sollte sich doch der Staat, so wie zum Beispiel in England oder so, oder zwischenzeitlich in den USA darauf konzentrieren, dass mehr Leute in der Lage sind, sich eine Wohnung zu kaufen und zu finanzieren, weil dann haben sie hinterher ihre Wohnung und haben ihre Alterssicherung und müssen im Alter halt nicht mehr noch mehr Miete zahlen und können dann halt im Zweifel ihren Kindern nochmal was vererben.
Also Alterssicherung ist alles.
Gut, also ich wiederhole jetzt nur mal so... Dieses Argument zu sagen, okay, so eigentlich wäre es doch am besten, wenn wir uns darauf konzentrieren, möglichst vielen Leuten den Weg zu ermöglichen, ihren Wohnraum zu besitzen. Was ist denn da das Gegenargument drauf?
Ich glaube, das erste Gegenargument ist, vor allem wenn wir doch sowohl im Vergleich zu England oder auch Spanien oder Italien uns das anschauen, ist einfach der Preis von Wohnungen in Deutschland, also die Herstellungskosten, die sind eigentlich so hoch, dass du das mit einem Eigentumserwerb bei einem durchschnittlichen Einkommen kaum darstellen kannst. Das heißt also, ab irgendeiner Stelle ist Wohnen insgesamt zu teuer geworden. Um zu sagen, das ist für große Schichten der Bevölkerung einfach kalkulierbar in Eigentum darstellbar. Ein zweiter Punkt, eigentlich galt ja das Mietwohnen als fortschrittlich gegenüber dem Eigentumswohnen, weil es gerade gesagt hat, das ist flexibel und wenn sich Lebensverhältnisse verändern, dann kannst du deine Wohnverhältnisse entsprechend anpassen, ohne sozusagen große Verpflichtungen des Eigentums dabei zu haben, wo dann immer gesagt wird, naja, das geht in England ja auch. Da verkauft man dann halt einfach immer seine Wohnung weiter. Aber wir haben glaube ich tatsächlich in Deutschland eine völlig andere Vorstellung von Eigentum. Also es gibt nicht diese Eigentum als kurzfristige Lösung, von der ich mich wieder abstoße, sondern Kultursoziologen nennen das so ein bisschen so das Modell irgendwie das 100 Jahre Haus oder das Eigentum für 100 Jahre. Also wer Eigentum erwirbt, der will das sein ganzes Leben lang behalten.
So ein Ewigkürzling.
Und das hängt auch ein bisschen mit dieser hohen Ausgangskosten der Qualität, die damit verbunden ist zusammen. Also das heißt, es ist ein Modell, was eigentlich den, sagen wir mal, Flexibilitätsansprüchen unserer modernen Gesellschaft eigentlich nicht mehr entspricht. Also Eigentum immer am selben Ort. Passt nicht zu dem, wie du arbeiten sollst, wie du flexibel sein sollst. Ein zweiter Aspekt ist sozusagen bei diesen hohen Eingangskriterien, den ökonomischen, das mir aufgefallen ist. Und Fefe hat ja schon so ein bisschen sich über diesen Mythos der Alterssicherung auch gerade lustig gemacht. Aber das, was mir am stärksten auffällt, ist, dass diejenigen, die sich unter den jetzigen Bedingungen in Berlin Eigentum leisten können, also die diese Eingangskriterien erfüllen, die müssten sich auch ohne Eigentumserwerb im Alter keine Sorgen machen. Also sozusagen, also die Voraussetzung zum Eigentumserwerb ist in der Regel, dass ich irgendein Vermögen mitbringe oder ererbt habe und dass ich ein halbwegs stabiles Einkommen habe. Ja, mit diesen beiden Voraussetzungen irgendwie ein größeres Vermögen und ein stabiles, dauerhaftes Einkommen muss man sich auch sonst im Alter keine Sorgen machen. Also das heißt, es stimmt zwar, dass Eigentümer in Deutschland, es denen im Alter besser geht als Mietern, aber das ist sozusagen kein Effekt des Eigentums, sondern dass die Eigentum gebildet haben, ist ein Effekt der sozialen Lage. Ja, und das darf man glaube ich nicht vergessen.
Aber ich will dich gerade noch mal ganz kurz hinterfragen, nur so des sportlichen Arguments halber.
Du Wadenbeißer, du.
So, wenn du jetzt mal sagst, okay, wenn wir den ganzen Steuerkram und so weglassen, dann könnten wir für so etwas wie 1800 Euro den Quadratmeter bauen. Das wäre so ungefähr die Zielgröße, auf die man da so kommt. Also jedenfalls irgendwas unter 2000 Euro den Quadratmeter. Heißt halt, wenn man so 25 Jahre oder so rechnet, kommt man dann auf 5, 6 Euro oder so was, die man dann da halt irgendwie abzahlt. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal an, der Start, wo wir jetzt sagen, okay, man macht halt so eine Art Mietkaufsystem. Also du erwirbst halt irgendwie sozusagen deine Wohnung für die Zeit, wo du da Miete zahlst und gibst die Miete nicht an irgendjemand ab. Also wäre das nicht eigentlich ein sehr viel sinnvollerer Weg daran zu gehen, also zu sagen, okay, man macht halt ein städtlich gefördertes System, dass der Staat nur sagt, ich will diese Wohnung kaufen, und du zahlst deine, ich denke, die Finanzierungskosten als Miete ab. Und wenn du halt ausziehst, kriegst du halt deinen Teil wieder. Also dann verkaufst du sozusagen die Wohnung, obwohl du sie noch nicht vollständig abbezahlt hast. Oder wenn du drinne bleibst, dann hast du sie halt irgendwann. Und am Ende hätten doch irgendwie alle mehr davon oder nicht?
Na, gerade bei diesem, also weil du jetzt sozusagen Eigentumserwerb im Rahmen vom Förderprogramm hatten wir ja vorhin gesagt, also bei der Kritik an dem bisherigen sozialen Wohnungsbauförderung ist das Problem, dass es nicht so dauerhaft ist. Ja, und die Vorstellung, dass ich als Staat mit Steuerbegünstigungen oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Vorteilen, zum Beispiel Erbbaupart verträgen und stattverkäufen, Preise reduziere, die macht ja eigentlich erst Sinn, wenn ich sage, und das hat einen langfristigen Effekt. Ja, und das, was wir in vielen Ländern, wo es so eine Form von Privatisierung öffentlicher Wohnungen an Einzelne gab, das Problem ist, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, also nenne es vielleicht das Problem der menschlichen Gier, wenn jemand Eigentum hat in so Lagen wie Berlin und der Preis verdoppelt sich, also dieser der Anreiz, sozusagen seine Wohnung sozusagen dann doch wieder auf den Markt zu schmeißen, also weil das ein einmaliges Angebot ist, was er jetzt plötzlich annehmen kann. Und dann ziehe ich halt nach Oranienburg und bin aber Millionär oder was auch immer.
Das war in Moskau, das ist ja ein frequentes Ding.
Ja, oder das gibt es in Lateinamerika, in den ganzen Ländern, wo es so über die Weltbank organisierte Programme gab, in den Favelas und Barrios, wo es informelle Siedlungen gab, zu sagen, wir müssen die Leute jetzt erst mal zu Eigentümern machen, damit die, weiß ich, Kredite annehmen können und sich dann von diesen Krediten eine Elektroleitung legen können, also eine Legalisierung von informellen Siedlungen, ging immer über Eigentumstitel. Und da ist ja auch ganz schnell immer festgestellt worden, sobald du sozusagen alle einfach nur in Eigentümer verwandelst, monopolisiert sich das durch einen Kauf. Und du hast sozusagen innerhalb von wenigen Jahren eine extrem einseitige Immobilienbesitzstruktur, weil alle versuchen, aus dem Eigentumstitel plötzlich Geld zu machen, kurzfristig Geld zu machen.
Und du, jemand kauft es halt auf und baut dann...
So, und dann produzierst du dir das Problem eigentlich immer wieder aufs Neue. Also das, was Eigentumsmärkte zeigen, oder Eigentums dominierte Wohnungsversorgungssysteme, sowohl in Russland, wenn man da die Großstädte sehen, als auch in Spanien, ist ja, dass das zwar einen Vorteil für die schafft, die in diesem System drin sind. Und wenn man sagt, die haben jetzt einen Vorteil und die sind hier von den Preissteigerungen, die jetzt gerade stattfinden, im Prinzip schon geschützt. Aber es ist ein System, das extrem hohe Zugangsschwellen setzt. Also Russland, klassisches Beispiel, ist ja nach dem Zusammenbruch des Sozialismus im Prinzip alle staatlichen Mietwohnungen nach so einem Vouchersystem mehr oder weniger verschenkt worden an die Mieter. Die haben sich dann in Eigentümer verwandelt. Manche von denen haben das dann verkauft und wurden sozusagen lieber auf der Datscha, um mit diesem Geld irgendwie umzugehen. Und in Russland gibt es so gut wie keinen staatlichen und auch keinen privaten Mietwohnungsmarkt. Also ganz wenige Prozentanteile der Wohnungsfamilie. Und das ist für Leute, die jetzt erwachsen werden, die bei ihren Eltern ausziehen wollen, so die müssten dann zu spekulativen Preisen gleich das Resthofproblem einsteigen in sozusagen einen Eigentumstitel. So und das ist nicht machbar. Und das funktioniert auch in Spanien und Italien eigentlich nur, weil im Prinzip sehr starke traditionale und familienbasierte Sicherungssysteme gibt, wo dann also die ganze Familie bis zur Großtante und der Großmutter Geld zusammentragen und zu sagen, jetzt soll das junge Ehepaar da sich die Eigentumswohnung kaufen können, weil sie sonst keine Wohnung kriegen und man weiß, dass sozusagen im Intergenerationsvertrag wirst du dann später, also von daher Sicherung im Alter, haha. Also sozusagen du hast die Verpflichtung, dann deine Enkel sozusagen beim Wohnungserwerb zu durchzureichen. So und das ist, also ich glaube, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Es gibt ja schon eine Menge Leute, die noch bei ihren Eltern wohnen, obwohl sie eigentlich gar nicht mehr wollen und so.
Genau, das nimmt zur Zeit ja also auch bei steigenden Mietpreisen natürlich zu.
Also ich würde auch gerne auf Amerika nochmal verweisen, denn da ist es sozusagen ein Regierungsprogramm gewesen, möglichst jedem ein eigenes Haus zu geben. Ja, weil dann hast du zwar kein Sozialsystem und keine Krankenversicherung, aber du hast ein Haus, ja, wenigstens etwas, sodass man was mal anfassen kann. Du siehst irgendwie, das System funktioniert für mich. Und der Effekt ist, dass die Leute abends, so wenn das Leben irgendwie in die letzte Phase übergeht, machen die etwas, das nennt sich Reverse Mortgage. Das ist sozusagen eine ungedrehte Hypothek. Sie schreiben das Haus einer Bank über und die Bank zahlt ihnen dafür monatlich eine Miete. Und die Bank spekuliert quasi darauf, dass die nur noch ein paar Jahre leben und dann gehört die in das Haus. Das heißt, du hast eben nichts mehr zum Vererben, ja. So, und das ist, was die Leute mit Altersversorge meinen. Das heißt, die leben auf Substanz und wenn sie länger als zehn Jahre noch leben, was angesichts der Gesundheitsversorgung nicht so wahrscheinlich ist, aber es kann halt vorkommen, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass du mit 90 nochmal obdachlos wirst. Also viele von diesen Systemen, das ist ein Phantom, was auf irgendwelchen, könnte irgendwie, Schönwetterszenarien basiert und das gibt keine Indiz meines Erachtens, dass das hier irgendwie besser ist. Ich glaube, wir sind auch zwar durch, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, im Wesentlichen haben wir alles abgehandelt, ja.
Wunderbar, also wir haben auch einiges gelernt.
Das war doch eine sehr informative Sendung.
Wie lange haben wir jetzt hier gemacht? Stundenlang, oder?
Zwei Stunden und fünfzig haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Das ist aber noch im Rahmen bei uns.
Ja, dann herzlichen Dank für die Teilnahme. Die hat doch sehr interessante Informationen. Wenn es euch gefallen hat, ihr wisst, wir haben da so einen Patreon-Dings und so einen Flatter-Button. Wir freuen uns natürlich über eure Mails.
Da müsst ihr viel flattern, damit ihr irgendwann hier noch mehr Eingangswohnung kaufen könnt.
Investieren wir ja auch mal in den Immobilienmarkt.
Genau, da können wir uns dann vielleicht mal einen Aschenbecher leisten. Nach einer kurzen Anmerkung zu Mails. Wir lesen alle Mails, die ihr uns schickt. Wir haben nicht wirklich Zeit, auf alle Mails zu antworten, aber wir lesen sie tatsächlich auch und freuen uns immer über Feedback-Anmerkungen, Korrekturen, Kritik, Hinweise, Themenanregungen. Also bitte, wenn wir nicht antworten, euch nicht die motivieren lassen, wir lesen es tatsächlich alles. Dann vielen Dank, Andrej, für das Vorbeikommen.
Vielen Dank für die vielen Fragen.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.